So, ich hoffe, ihr habt schön brav und fleißig mitgezählt. Wenn ihr diese Musik hört und außerdem mitbekommt, dass der letzte Donnerstag im Monat ist, dann wisst ihr jetzt ist Chaos Radio Zeit. Das heißt, der Chaos Computer Club hat die Fritz Studios geentert, ist hier am Start und wird euch die nächsten zwei Stunden mit einem Thema seiner Wahl erfreuen. Heute geschieht das in Gestalt von Harald Welte und Andy Müller-Maguhn vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallo und guten Abend. Sehr schön. Und das Thema, das ihr mitgebracht habt, ist eins, das könnte man fast schon als altes Steckenpferd bezeichnen, das aus aktuellem Anlass wieder aus der Kiste geholt wird. Es handelt sich um Schnüffeleien, um Überwachung, insbesondere heute um Handyschnüffeleien. Also die Art und Weise, wie wir diese neuartigen Rundfunkempfangsgeräte, die manche auch Mobiltelefone nennen, überwachen, abhören, mitschneiden, was auch immer der Typ, dem das Ding gehört, machen kann, all das werdet ihr heute erklären. Und vielleicht auch, könnten wir kurz so reden, ob das alles so seine Richtigkeit hat oder nicht, mit den gesetzmäßigen Überwachungen oder den ungesetzmäßigen. Schauen wir mal. Aktuellen Anlass, an aktuellen Anlass gibt es natürlich, und das ist Dresden, die Geschichte dürfte euch über den Weg gelaufen sein, im letzten Monat sogar, also das ist schon eine Weile her, da kommen immer noch wieder neue Sachen raus. In Dresden gab es eine Demo und da hat die Polizei gedacht, hey, lass doch mal gucken, weil alles so da war und hat eine sogenannte Funkzellenauswertung gemacht. Was das genau ist, das werden wir gleich erklären, nur noch um die Dimension klar zu machen. Es hieß erst so, ja, das sind ein paar hundert Mobiltelefonbenutzer wurden da so mitgeschnitten. Dann hieß es auf einmal so, ja, war ein bisschen mehr, 40.000 oder so. Und dann ist jetzt noch letztens rausgekommen, es gibt noch einen größeren Fall, der liegt ein bisschen weiter zurück, da waren es dann gleich zwei Millionen. Also ihr benutzt euer Handy und die Polizei denkt dann irgendwann so, hey, lass doch mal gucken, was der komische Typ da macht. Was da genau passiert ist und ob es alles rechtmäßig ist und was man vielleicht noch so alles mit euren Handys anstellen kann, das wollen wir heute hier im Chaosradio klären. Jetzt geht es los, eine Funkzellenauswertung ist da geschehen. Was zur Hölle ist eine Funkzellenauswertung?
Ja, Funkzellenauswertung, das ist ich würde fast sagen schon amtsdeutsch und bezeichnet eben die Auswertung der Polizei von sogenannten Verkehrsdaten des Mobilfunks. Das sind Daten, die anfallen bei der Benutzung von Mobilfunknetzen. Und da wird dann über einen richterlichen Beschluss die Polizei zu dem jeweiligen Netzbetreiber, also Vodafone, die Mobile, E+, oder O2, um auch alle genannt zu haben, schön ausgewogen berichten, geht und sagt, wir hätten jetzt gerne mal diese sogenannten Verkehrsdaten. Das sind also wer hat wann mit wem telefoniert, wo waren die Telefone zu dem Zeitpunkt. Also auch Daten darüber, wenn Datendienst, Internet über Telefone genutzt wurde, wann ist das passiert, von welchen IP-Adressen aus und so weiter. Diese ganzen Verkehrsdaten werden dann von den Netzbezweiflern an die Polizei weitergeleitet und die Polizei versucht damit irgendwas zu ermitteln.
Das ist dann vielleicht meine nächste Frage, aber nochmal, muss ich andersherum formulieren, Verkehrsdaten sind quasi alles, außer der Inhalt, worum es eigentlich ging, oder?
Nein, also man muss jetzt zunächst unterscheiden, es gibt Verkehrsdaten, das ist tatsächlich wer telefoniert mit wem und dann gibt es die sogenannten Begleitumstände der Telekommunikation, wie sie im Gesetz heißen. Das ist der genaue Aufenthaltsort der Zelle, der auch sozusagen nach GPS dann gleich abgeglichen werden kann. Das heißt, du hast da nicht die Gesprächsinhalte, aber wer spricht mit wem und welches Telefon ist wo. Das beinhaltet natürlich auch die Telekommunikationsvorgänge, wie zum Beispiel, wenn jemand eine SMS schickt. Auch das ist in den Verkehrsdaten in diesem Fall enthalten.
Okay, also sie wissen quasi alles, außer worüber ich geredet oder geschrieben habe.
Genau, die Inhalte sind nicht Bestandteil der Verkehrsdaten.
Okay, na immerhin. Warum macht man sowas, also was kann man dann damit rausfinden?
Ja, im Grunde leider sehr viel. Zunächst denkt man vielleicht, es sind ja nur die Verkehrsdaten und nicht die Inhalte. Das ist ja noch nicht so relevant, aber wenn man das mal über einen längeren Zeitraum vor allem sich anschaut, bekommt man ein sehr genaues Profil, vor allem durch die Positionsdaten. Also wer sein Telefon den ganzen Tag mit sich rumträgt und eingeschaltet hat, der hat permanent Informationen dazu, wo er ist, an die Polizei weitergegeben in dem Fall.
Da kann man ein schönes Bewegungsprofil erstellen. Wisst ihr in dem Fall von Dresden jetzt, wie viele Daten die sich da haben geben lassen? Also vom Zeitraum her. Ich habe jetzt gelesen, bei dem Fall aus 2009, wo die zwei Millionen Daten sich da gegeben haben, da sind es fünf ganze Tage, da kann man schon ganz schön was mit machen. Wie lange braucht man denn, um so ein, damit man ordentlich was anstellen kann? Die werden ja wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht sagen, irgendwie gibt man jetzt hier alle Daten von 12 Uhr bis 12 Uhr 10, sondern es wird wahrscheinlich schon ein längerer Zeitraum sein, oder?
Also, wenn ich es richtig sehe, haben die in Dresden tatsächlich nur zwischen 13, 17 und 30, also 4, 5 Stunden, heißt es hier. Allerdings, die Realität kommt hier so ein bisschen Scheibchenweise. Also, man muss da ein bisschen gucken, es gibt Andeutung, dass nicht nur eine Funkzellenauswertung, also eine netzzeitige Speicherung und Übermittlung der Daten stattgefunden hat, sondern auch der Einsatz von technischen Geräten der Polizei selbst, mit denen man GSM-Luftschnittstellen, wie sie heißen, also die Kommunikation zwischen dem Mobiltelefon und den Funkzellen abhören kann, entweder durch einen IMSI-Catcher oder durch passive oder sogenannte SEMI-Passive. Das sind dann aktive Komponenten, die Realität ist hier noch nicht vollständig transparent rekonstruiert, um es mal vorsichtig zu sagen.
Okay, also wir können ja zu dem, was diese IMSI-Catcher und SEMI-Acmi was?
SEMI-Passive ist so die, ja das ist so eine höfliche Herstellerumschreibung, das sind also Geräte, die wir nachher noch in Detail beschreiben können, die nicht nur passiv zuhören können und funktionellen Daten ausführen können oder auch Gesprächsinhalte mitlesen und mithören können, sondern die auch intervenieren können, die beispielsweise eine SMS, die an jemanden geschickt wird, abfangen können und dann eine andere SMS weiter schicken, um dem seine Beziehung zu beenden oder andere Dinge zu tun.
Wir packen jetzt in unser Kapitel das ganze Programm, ja, konnte man so sagen, ok.
Funktionellenauswertung, ich würde noch gerne kurz da beleiben, Funktionellenauswertung, wie genau wird das dann ausgehört, das kriegen die irgendwie, also ich stelle mir jetzt tatsächlich so ein bisschen Lachen vor, die kriegen jetzt einen Ausdruck, die haben eine Datenbank von 896.000 Datensätze, das sind die kompletten, also das ist zumindest die Zahl, die ich hier vorliegen habe, wo eben alle Verkehrsdaten sind, das heißt alle Kommunikationsvorgänge, das heißt, dass jemand abgehend telefoniert, dass er angerufen wird, dass einer es sendet oder empfängt oder in anderer Art und Weise, Stichwort Internet, eine Verbindung aufbaut. Das sind also nicht die, wenn man so eine nicht netzzeitige Auswertung macht, sondern eine technische Auswertung macht, also quasi die Luftschönstelle abhört, dann hat man natürlich noch viel mehr. Dann hat man auch das Gerät, das sich alle paar Minuten mal meldet und sagt, hier bin ich mit den Daten und so fort. Es sind hier immerhin nur in Anführungszeichen die Verkehrsdaten, aber eben alle Geräte in der Dresdner Innenstadt.
Was passiert da mit diesen Daten?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Da können wir nur mutmaßen, was die Polizei genau damit macht. Es sind halt doch sehr viele Daten, vor allem muss man immer berücksichtigen, es geht halt nicht nur um Telefonie, da kann man noch sagen, wie viele Telefonate für euch am Tag, es sind ja nur ein paar Datensätze. Aber gerade mit den modernen Smartphones, jedes Mal wenn das Telefon die E-Mails abfragt und synchronisiert, jedes Mal wenn ich irgendwie eine Twitter-Nachricht schreibe oder sonst irgendwas, das sind alles einzelne Kommunikationsvorgänge und da werden jeweils entsprechend Verkehrsdaten generiert.
Ja, also was man vielleicht sagen kann, was die Polizei mit den Daten macht und auch was andere Institutionen mit den Daten machen, man unterscheidet in der Überwachungswirtschaft, um die mal so zu benennen, tatsächlich zwischen den Erhebungsinstrumenten, also SIGINT oder Common Signal Intelligence oder Communication Intelligence, das sind quasi Abhöhereinrichtungen und dem, was man danach mit den Daten macht, also die Auswertungskapazitäten, das sind die sogenannten Intelligence Support Systems. Das sind beispielsweise Systeme, um aus Verkehrsdaten Organigramme zu rekonstruieren, um Verbindungen zwischen Menschen, Organisationen, Ereignissen, also nicht nur Profile von den überwachten Teilnehmern zu erstellen, sondern auch einfach Muster zu erkennen, wie welche Teilnehmer sich anders verhalten, nachdem irgendetwas passiert ist, was natürlich insbesondere im Kontext von solchen politischen Sachen hier, wie in Dresden, interessant ist. Und wer sich danach schon mal ein bisschen googeln will hier am Radiogerät, googelt sich einfach mal ISS, Intelligent Support Systems. Es gibt eine gleichnamige Messe, die jedes Jahr dreimal stattfindet. Einmal in Dubai, wo sich ja das Herz der fast demokratischen Länder im Mittleren Osten versammeln. Dann in Amerika, was ja auch bekannt ist für seine vorbildliche Wahrung von Menschenrechten und Privatsphäre und so fort. Und dann noch mal in Prag, warum auch immer in Prag, aber jedenfalls in Europa, wo diese Instrumente, mit denen man eben Auswertungen machen kann, das ist eine ganze Bandbreite, fängt wie gesagt an, von Verkehrsdaten zu Organigramm, Analyse, Software, Spracherkennung.
Um das mal ganz kurz abzuschließen, diesen kleinen Ausflug ist es also so, man stellt sich ja mal vor als normaler Mensch, es gibt jetzt diese staatlichen Behörden, die dürfen auch irgendwie so dieses Überwachungskram machen, es wird immer stark gestritten, was jetzt dürfen und nicht. Es ist aber nicht so, dass sie das alles selber bauen, sondern es gibt dahinter eine Industrie.
Ja, absolut und es ist also diese Industrie, ich habe einige Präsentationen von diesen Veranstaltungen, die bewerben dann auch Sachen ungeachtet der gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen, sondern einfach auf Basis der technischen Möglichkeiten, beispielsweise die massenhafte Erhebung von Verkehrsdaten, wird dann massiv besorben mit, why catch a single target when you can cover them all. Frei nach dem Motto, Festplatten kosten kein echtes Geld mehr und es ist einfach viel ökonomischer, alle immer abzuhören und dann später auszuwerten, wer interessant, verdächtig in einem Vorgang auftaucht. Und mit solchen technologischen Konzepten, die wie gesagt völlig frei, weil die dann ja auch im Mittleren Osten, da brauchst du ja gar nicht diskutieren mit gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen, aber in Europa habe ich den Eindruck, es ist so, dass die Regierungsvertreter, die da hingehen der diversen Organisationen, das ist ja nicht nur Polizei, sondern auch die Nachrichtendienste, dass die dann auf lustige Ideen kommen und so was wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung sozusagen der Effekt, die Auswirkung von Marketingmaßnahmen dieser Industrie sind.
Aha, okay, wir basteln euch einen schönen bunten Flyer. Guck mal hier, alle Gespräche abhören, das ist ganz einfach, und dann basteln wir uns einen Gesetz dazu. Apropos, jetzt gab es diese Funkzellenauswertung in Dresden und die ist ja von der Polizei durchgeführt worden, was mich zumindest zu der Vermutung bringt, dass es dahinter einen irgendwie gearteten, demokratisch legitimierten, juristischen Prozess gibt, der das Ganze möglich gemacht hat.
Hey, du glaubst doch auch noch an Märchen.
Ich wollte das erst mal nur so als These in den Raum stellen und euch dann fragen, wie sieht denn das aus, wenn die Polizei so eine Funkzellenauswertung machen will, was muss denn dazu passieren?
Ja, also das Gesetz sieht da im Wesentlichen eine ganze Reihe unterschiedlicher Möglichkeiten vor, aber im Wesentlichen kann man sie aufteilen in einmal eben die sogenannte richterliche Anordnung. Das heißt, die Polizei respektive die Staatsanwaltschaft legt irgendwie ein Schreiben vor einem zuständigen Amtsrichter und sagt, ja, wir haben ja diesen jenes und die und jenen Straftaten und wir brauchen dazu Ermittlungen, diese oder jenen Daten und der Richter möge doch bitte darüber entscheiden, ob es denn erlaubt sein soll, dass die Polizei diese Daten bei den Netzbetreibern abfragt oder eben dort anfordert. Und der Richter entscheidet dann darüber. Das klingt jetzt erstmal alles auf dem Papier natürlich ganz wunderbar. Da gibt es einen Richter, der kriegt da was vorgelegt, der muss sich da darüber Gedanken machen, der kann sich dann entscheiden.
Also der kann einfach so sagen ja oder nein sagen und dann ist gut.
Die Statistik sagt allerdings, dass er glaube ich in ungefähr 99, 99% immer ja sagt.
Ich glaube es ist nicht ganz so viel, Andy, aber ja, in überwiegenden Fällen sagt er ja, das liegt wohl auch daran, dass er ein nein begründen muss und ein ja hingegen nicht. Das heißt also ein nein zu sagen ist viel mehr Aufwand als ja zu sagen. Und ich meine, wenn man jetzt ständig solche Sachen vorgelegt bekommt, dann ist man natürlich schon auch ein bisschen unter Stress steht vielleicht, dass man vielleicht geneigt irgendwie zu sagen ja.
Ja. Gut, das haben die Dresden auch so gemacht, die haben dann gesagt, okay Richter, guck mal, wir wollen mal ein bisschen Funkzellenauswertung machen, sag mal ja oder ne und der ist auch kein Bock, irgendwie jetzt eine Begründung für die Ablehnung zu schreiben, macht mal. Also es muss ja wahrscheinlich sagen, auch einen Anlass geben, es ist ja bei manchen Dingen so, dass nur bestimmte Straftaten erlauben, dass dann bestimmte Rechtsmittel angewandt werden. Ist das bei dieser Funkzellenauswertung auch so oder ist es einfach egal? Also da ist jemand schwarz gefahren und wir vermuten, er ist in der Innenstadt auf, wir wollen eine Funkzellenauswertung machen. Geht das auch oder?
Das wird nicht gehen. Also ich denke, da wird auch der langweiligste Richter der Republik irgendwie sagen, hey, das ist nicht eine Straftat, bei der das erlaubt ist. Es gibt da dann immer sogenannte Katalog-Straftaten zum Beispiel. Das sind immer so schöne Begriffe, die da im Raum stehen. Also es gibt einfach eine Liste, die natürlich auch immer gern erweitert wird an Straftaten, bei denen also derartige Überwachungsmaßnahmen angeordnet werden dürfen. Und das muss dann eben so was sein. Und das, ich sag mal, ich hab jetzt den Katalog grad nicht vorliegen, muss ich nochmal irgendwie aufmachen. Aber also in dem Fall von Dresden ging es wohl um die Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung.
Und wieso spielt da diese Demo noch Rolle?
Ja, da sind wohl Ausschreitungen gegen Polizisten auch unter anderem passiert. Und das scheint dann wohl offensichtlich gereicht zu haben.
Aber jetzt ist es ja so, so wie du es erklärt hast, scheint das ja seinen Weg gegangen zu sein. Also irgendwie man merkt davon halt was man will, aber es scheint sozusagen legal zu sein. Warum gab es diesen großen Aufschrei dann?
Ich denke, das liegt im Wesentlichen an der Poste. Und insbesondere der Taz, die sich da extrem dahinter gestellt haben. Ja, die gesetzlichen Möglichkeiten sind in den letzten zehn Jahren oder so extrem ausgebaut worden. Es ging mit dem TKG 2002 glaube ich an, das Telekommunikationsgesetz, die zugehörige Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung, TKÜV, nebst Anlagen und sonstigen Dingen. Also die Überwachungsbefugnisse sind extrem ausgeweitet worden. Es betrifft ja nicht nur die Polizei, die jetzt in normalen Fällen ermittelt. Überwachungsbefugnisse gibt es auch für den MAD und den BND und den Zoll in bestimmten Fällen.
MAD ist diese Zeitschrift mit dem Alfred E. Neumann und welcher ist der Heimdienst?
Unser militärischer Abschirmdienst, der neulich mal abgeschafft werden sollte, aber seitdem unser ehemaliger Innenminister jetzt Verteidigungsminister ist, hat das Projekt gestoppt. Das heißt, den MAD gibt es weiterhin und er ist für die Sicherheit der Wehrstreitkräfte, aber auch die Sicherheit der Verbündeten, also unserer NATO-Partner, der amerikanischen Kasernen und so weiter.
Wie viele Geheimnisse haben wir denn überhaupt? Also nur mal so, okay, bevor wir jetzt wieder gehangen, okay, warte.
Ja, hab ich zufällig.
Nein, okay, also ich will jetzt sagen, nicht die Sendung zu einer Geheimdienst-Sendung machen, aber das ist mir völlig gerade aufgefallen, also wenn jemand sagt Geheimdienst Deutschland, dann denke ich, okay, BND.
Ja, wir haben noch den Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und die Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz und wir haben noch das Zollkriminalamt, was eigentlich auch als Geheimdienst gelten kann, weil es zumindest geheimdienstliche Befugnisse hat, auch wenn es eigentlich...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da habe ich jetzt gerade heute einen Artikel gelesen, dass die gerne auch Telekommunikations überwachen wollen, um Schwarzarbeiter zu fangen.
Ja, was dann nicht mal so gerade auf der Tagesordnung für die Begründung dasteht.
Also es ist halt wirklich so, dass dieser Katalog, es kommt nur drauf an, welche Überwachungsmaßnahme wird jetzt beantragt, wann darf die angewandt werden, aber die werden eben ständig erweitert. Da gibt es also bestimmte Verstöße gegen das Arzneimittelgesetz, also Betäubungsmittel und dergleichen. Ja, es gibt eben die kriminelle Vereinigung, terroristische Taten natürlich, irgendwie Sexualstraftaten, was auch immer. Also es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Straftaten und das wird eben immer wieder erweitert. Das heißt dann, in dem Fall bemüht sich also eben der Zoll darum, dass hier weitere Straftaten im Bereich der Schwarzarbeit aufgenommen werden, bei denen dann eine bestimmte Überwachungsmaßnahme wie die Funkzellenauswertung angewandt werden kann.
Woher kommt es eigentlich so denn, dieses Bedürfnis, diese Überwachungsdinger immer ausweiten zu wollen? Macht es für die Ermittlungsbehörden das tatsächlich sozusagen so viel einfacher?
Ja, naja, die sind natürlich auch ein bisschen schreibtisch faul und internetaffin geworden. Ja, das kann man glaube ich schon so sagen, dass es ein bequemes Instrumentarium ist, wenn man das jetzt mal vergleicht mit den Leuten, auch schon den Leuten, die Autos zu verwandeln. Da musst du jemanden rausschicken, der muss dann so ein Ding anbringen, das Ding kostet relativ viel Geld. Also wir haben ja jetzt durch diese NNQ, liegt bei der Bundespolizei, gibt es ja eine gute Übersicht über alle Hersteller dieser Instrumente und auch so die Art des Einsatzes. So ein Ding kostet irgendwie 1.000, 2.000 Euro. Dann muss ich da mal hinstellen und so fort. Also diese Funkzellenauswertung und diese anderen Sachen sind vergleichsweise kostengünstig.
Ja, also vor allem die Funkzellenerbewachung. Ja, weil die Daten liegen bei dem Operator, also bei dem Netzanbieter, die muss ich nur anfordern. Da kriege ich dann, also die Polizei kann dann noch, wie es im Gesetz so schön steht, den Weg bestimmen, auf dem die Daten zu ihr gelangen. Also die können dann sagen, jetzt mal hier auf dieses Speichermedium oder so, oder diesen Übertragungsweg und dann habe ich die Daten. Und wenn ich mal überlege, was weiß ich, wir reden hier über 800.000 oder 2 Millionen Datensätze, das ist ja für jeden Popelcomputer von vor zehn Jahren irgendwie ein leichtes, die zu indizieren, zu cross-referenzieren, da eben Graphen zu malen, wer hat wann wen telefoniert und wo sind irgendwelche Gruppen. Da gibt es ja genügend Möglichkeiten, diese Daten dann zu durchforsten, mit ganz wenig Technik.
Also der Pfeil geht quasi so, also wir machen, wir überwachen mehr, weil das einfacher und unaufwendiger ist, als sozusagen immer die einzelnen Leute eine Start zu bringen. Dabei fallen, das ist halt die Technik, einfach mehr Daten an, als wir brauchen. Und dann können wir doch gleich nochmal gucken, ob da nicht noch was dabei ist. Ist das so grob der Ablauf?
Ja, ich denke schon. Was ich jetzt gerade noch erwähnen wollte, weil du sagtest, warum ist der Aufschrei so groß? Also diese Gesetze, wie gesagt, seit vielen Jahren, also spätestens seit dem 11. September 2001, sind die Gesetze extrem verschärft worden in Bezug auf Überwachung. Und der CCC zum Beispiel und andere Bürgerrechtsorganisationen warnen ja schon seit vielen Jahren und versuchen da irgendwie die Öffentlichkeit darauf aufmerksam zu machen. Und wie wir jetzt auch sehen, bereits vor Jahren gab es da Fälle mit Millionen von Datensätzen usw. Es ist an der Tagesordnung, dass derartige Auswertungen gemacht werden. Und der Aufschrei kommt eigentlich meiner Meinung nach viel zu spät. Und es ist gut, dass er kommt.
Ja, vielleicht ist es einfach so, man hat ja eh nichts zu verbergen, wenn man nichts verbrochen hat. Das ist ja so ein landläufiger Argument, was du da mal kommst.
Ja, aber man hat ja auch vielleicht was zu beschützen. Also es ist schon so, dass diese Daten, wenn sie einmal anfallen, und das ist ja auch unsere Hauptkritik an der Vorresteinspeicherung, in dem Moment, wo die Daten anfallen und gespeichert sind, ist eine Kontrolle der Hand, aber sei es eine technische Kontrolle oder eine gesetzliche, einfach ganz schwierig. Und das heißt, warum sollte man dann irgendwie glauben, dass Polizeidienststellen oder Nachrichtendienste sicherere Computer haben als andere? Weil man hat ja tatsächlich in den letzten Wochen...
Das sind amtliche Computer.
Genau, das wollte ich sagen. Die haben schon doch so einen schicken Aufkleber.
Ja, mit amtlichen Sicherheitslack, wie man jetzt seit den letzten Wochen weiß. Trojaner verseucht, ganze Dienststellen, bundesweit mit automatischen Updates von irgendwelchen jugendlichen Hackern, die noch nicht mal... Also das war schon interessant, was da bei der NN Crew alles so...
Ja, okay, das möchte ich jetzt erkunden, weil der jetzt schon häufiger gefallen ist. NN Crew, Hack, Bürocomputer, kurze Zusammenfassung, was da passiert?
Nicht Bürocomputer, sondern die NN Crew hat eine Leak-Site aufgemacht. Wir haben vor jetzt ungefähr, na zweiter Woche oder irgendwas, die war in Russland gehurstet und enthielt einen recht umfangreichen Datenbestand eines Computers der Bundespolizei, wo die GPS-Tracking-Abteilung sozusagen ihren Dienst angeboten hat. Das heißt, das sind Dienststellen, die so kleine Geräte den Leuten unter die Autos kleben, beziehungsweise mit starken Magneten bleiben diese Geräte selbsthaft unter den Autos. Die haben einen GPS-Empfänger, sammeln also die Positionsdaten, wo so ein Fahrzeug sich befindet, und senden die dann per GSM-Funk, also sind das anrufbar per GPS, oder senden die automatisch zu einem Server der Polizei, wo dann, in diesem Fall waren es so Zollvergänger und solche Geschichten, also Zollabteilungen zumindest, die da beteiligt waren, sich die Daten sammeln. Es waren aber auch Geräte dabei, die eine Audioüberwachung von Autos ermöglichen. Und es gab eben später, nachdem dieser Server gehackt war, die waren da offenbar mehrere Monate drin. Sie haben behauptet, über ein Jahr, ob das stimmt, sei dahingestellt. Aber jedenfalls hatten sie verschiedene Trojaner wohl verteilt. Und in diesem Datenstand, der dann im Internet stand, war unter anderem auch die Rufnummerliste. Das heißt, die GSM-Rufnummer dieser Wanzen. Und ein paar Tage später, nachdem die schon im Netz war, hat da mal jemand schweißesherbe angefangen, die Rufnummer anzurufen. Und ist ohne Authentifizierung, das heißt ohne Sicherheitsmaßnahme, gleich mal in so eine Audiowanze reingelaufen. Das heißt, da konnte irgendwelche Leute belauschen. Und da muss man sich schon die Frage stellen, ob diese Polizeidienststellen irgendwie so gewisse Grundsätze von sicherem Vorgehen bei installieren von solchen Anlagen. Also ohne Authentifizierung, da wird es sogar schwierig, daraus einen Gesetzesverstoß zu machen. Weil nach 202a beispielsweise, das ist der Strafgesetzbuch, Zweite Wirtschaftskriminalitätsgesetz, ist das Ausspielen von Daten nur dann strafbar, wenn die Daten gegen das Ausspielen geschützt sind.
Besonders geschützt.
Ja, besonders geschützt sind, genau. Und wenn man aber einfach so Daten im Netz verteilt und keine Schutzmaßnahmen einbaut, wenn man rufend mal anruft, dass man dann Leute belauschen kann, dann ist das kein Schutz gegen die Daten.
Ich halte also fest, die Polizeiwanze anzurufen, ist total legal, weil sie hätten es ja schützen können. Weiß man denn eigentlich, wie dieser Hack passiert ist? Ich bringe als Vergleich immer schön gerne Sony an. Sony ist ja über eine SQL-Injection gehackt worden und das ist sozusagen mehrere Monate in mehreren Kapiteln von Sony in verschiedenen Ländern. Und SQL-Injection, ohne es genauer erklären zu wollen, ist das kleine 1x1. War das so ähnlich? Oder weiß man das, was da passiert ist?
Also das weiß man nur in Teilen und auch nur durch die Aussagen der Hacker, die hier ein bisschen, also man hat uns ein bisschen in Einnung, das sind auch Jugendliche, die sehr stolz darauf waren, das getan zu haben und darüber auch so viel gesprochen haben, aber jedenfalls sind sie angeblich in irgendeiner Form in den Server eingestiegen, wahrscheinlich durch eine Update-Funktion der Software, die diese GPS-Tracking-Software der Server sozusagen eingebaut hatte.
Also auch was, was man normalerweise eigentlich in sicher haben will?
Ja, das will man in sicher haben, aber der Polizei hatte den günstigsten Anbieter gewählt.
Ich denke, wir sollten nicht jetzt zu viel auf diesem einen Fall drauf bleiben. Das soll jetzt hier nur als Beweis oder als Beleg dienen, dass es durchaus äußerst sicherheitsrelevante Daten von deutschen Polizeibehörden in unglaublich wenig IT-mäßig geschützt gibt. Und dass man das halt immer mit berücksichtigen muss, wenn man sagt, ja, das ist ja nur die Polizei und das sind nur die Entwicklungsbehörden. Diese sensiblen Daten und die werden ja auch alle gleich gelöscht.
Das wäre die nächste Frage zur Funkzellenauswertung gewesen. Jetzt sind da aktuell 40.000 Leute betroffen. Kriegen die irgendwann mitgeteilt, dass ihre Daten da erhoben wurden? Oder ist es so, wo haben wir jetzt? Also gibt es da eine Art Informationspflicht von den offiziellen Stellen?
Wir als CCC haben das immer gefordert, dass es verpflichtend eine Mitteilung der Betroffenen gibt. Leider ist das meines Kenntnisses nach nie so umgesetzt worden. Es gibt Zollbestimmungen und es gibt, also nicht Zoll, sondern soll, es soll gemacht werden. Aber in der Realität wird es dann halt doch sehr selten gemacht. Also es gab dazu, glaube ich, mal eine parlamentarische Anfrage vor ein paar Jahren im Bundestag und da war das, also wirklich unterferner liefen, wie viel Prozent der Opfer dieser Überwachungsmaßnahmen tatsächlich mal benachsichtigt wurden nach Abschluss der Maßnahme.
Also es gibt in der Theorie auch im Gesetz eine Benachrichtigung des Betroffenen, wie es heißt. Und die ist allerdings nur dann vorgesehen, wenn durch die Benachrichtigung den Ermittlungsbehörden bei den Ermittlungen keine Nachteile entstehen könnten. Und das wird regelmäßig in Anspruch genommen, dass sie also sagen, ihnen würden dadurch taktische Nachteile entstehen, dass Leute wissen, dass sie abgehört wurden.
Aber das wird bei solchen Großmaßnahmen, wie jetzt hier diese Funkzellenauswertung mit 300.000 betroffenen Leuten, also in diesen 800.000 Datensätzen ungefähr 300.000 Leute oder Telefone waren da beteiligt, da kann ich natürlich irgendwie nicht sagen, bei allen 300.000 würde es die Ermittlungen beeinträchtigen, wenn man die hinterher benachrichtigen würde. Dann würde man behaupten, dass die alle volle kriminell sind und alle irgendwie...
Ja, die Dresdner, müsste man mal gucken.
Vor allem dann die ganzen aus der Restrepublik angereist, gewaltbereiten Jugendlichen in hunderttausender Zahl.
Dann haben wir jetzt also den aktuellen Anlass geklärt, warum wir heute darüber reden, wie man Mobilfunk-Telefone so schön überwachen, aushorchen und nachtracken kann. Wir werden gleich nach dem Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr nochmal über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung sprechen, also ein gesetzliches Instrument, das sie überhaupt erst möglich gemacht hat, und danach um die ganzen anderen Dinge zu sprechen kommen, die man mit Handys noch so anstellen kann, aber vorher wie gesagt erstmal das fritz informe Nachrichtenwetter und Verkehr. Genauer gesagt heißt das heute Chaos Radio. Das ist nämlich der letzte Donnerstag im Monat. Und Andy Müller-Maguhn und Harald Welte vom Chaos Computer Club sind hier und erklären mal, was man mit diesen gesellschaftlichen Mobiltelefonen, die ihr alle, und das sag ich mal ausnahmslos, alle in der Hosentasche habt, so anstellen kann, überwachungsmäßig. Wir hatten in der ersten halben Stunde schon kurz geklärt, was in Dresden gerade abgegangen ist, wo mehrere Zehntausend Leute, wie heißt das, Bewegungsdaten, Verkehrsdaten erfasst wurden. Ist das das richtige Amtswort?
Mehrere Hunderttausend.
Wer bietet mehr? Könnt ihr anrufen, 033 171 9711 0, just saying. Wir haben darüber gesprochen, es gibt, also wie man das macht, was da alles anfällt, warum die Behörden das so geil finden, dass man das alles irgendwie an Start bringen kann. Wenn ihr das jetzt verpasst habt, könnt ihr das gerne nachhören. Wir können es nicht nochmal erklären, weil die Sendung hat ja nur zwei Stunden und es gibt noch so viel zu bereden. Unter anderem wollen wir noch mal kurz genauer über das Instrument Vorratsdatenspeicherung sprechen, was da eine Rolle gespielt hat. Also jetzt im aktuellen Fall nicht, weil da ist ja sozusagen relativ kurz nachdem der Tag war, an dem die Daten angefallen sind, auch gesagt worden, wir wollen es jetzt haben. Wie ist es denn im Moment? Wie lange halten die Mobilfunkbetreiber diese Daten überhaupt vor? Also wie lange kann die Polizei überhaupt sagen, okay, ich möchte jetzt eine Funkzellenauswertung machen?
Ja, das ist nicht so ganz genau definiert. Also es gibt da halt unterschiedliche Bestimmungen, die zum Tragen kommen. Zum einen muss man ja erst mal sagen, welche Daten fallen denn technisch notwendig in so einem Mobilfunknetz an? Das ist natürlich klar, vor allem zu Abrechnungszwecken brauche ich irgendwie, wer hat wann wie lange telefoniert, sonst kann ich dem keine Rechnung schreiben. Dann wenn es um Einzelverbindungsnachweis und solche Dinge geht, muss ich natürlich auch irgendwie, um diesen Einzelverbindungsnachweis ausstellen zu können, als Netzbetreiber muss ich diese Daten haben, wer hat da wann telefoniert und so. Auch bei Datendiensten, eben welches Datenvolumen ist angefallen und so weiter, welche Bandbreiten, wie lange, das ist ja alles Teil der Berechnung unter Umständen in diesen Tarifen. Dann gibt es auf der anderen Seite eben das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz und die Datenschutzgesetze der Länder, in denen auch drin steht. Daten sind eben nur so lange zu erheben, solange das notwendig ist. Und überflüssige Daten müssen dann eben gelöscht werden oder gar nicht erst erhoben werden. Das ist die Datensparsamkeit und zum anderen gibt es auch im Telekommunikationsgesetz entsprechende Anforderungen an die Netzbetreiber, dass sie Daten, die nicht notwendig sind zur Erbringung ihrer Dienste und so weiter, speichern. Das ist mal die eine Seite, dass man eigentlich gesetzlich sagt, so wenig wie möglich speichern, nur dass was nötig ist, um diese Dienstleistung zu erbringen. Und dann gibt es dem gegenüber eben andere gesetzliche Bestimmungen. Diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung zum Beispiel, die gekippt wurde, ich denke, da kommen wir gleich nochmal dazu. Aber die Frage, wie lange liegen diese Daten bei dem Netzbetreiber vor, das hängt von dem Netzbetreiber ab, wie der seine Abläufe strukturiert und was die intern dort beschlossen haben, zusammen mit der Justizabteilung und so weiter, was für sie sozusagen im Rahmen der Gesetze irgendwie Sinn macht und im Rahmen ihres Betriebs. Für uns als CCC ist es natürlich schon fraglich, warum so viele Daten überhaupt vorgehalten werden im Moment. Zum Beispiel die Positionsinformation, wo war dieses Telefon, ist für Abrechnungszwecke völlig irrelevant. Es gibt vereinzelt Tarife, wo es so eine Homezone oder ähnliche Konzepte gibt. Gibt es das noch? Ich weiß nicht, ob es das noch gibt. Ich denke, bestimmt. In dem Tarifdschungel, den wir haben im Mobilfunkmarkt, gibt es garantiert mindestens einen Anbieter, der noch mindestens eine Zahl an Tarifen hat, die sowas machen. Aber auch da, dass man sozusagen pauschal sämtliche Positionsdaten sämtlicher Telefonbesitzer speichert und vorhält, da muss man sich schon fragen, warum ist das denn tatsächlich nötig für Abwechslungszwecke?
Also was die Dresdner Staatsanwaltschaft beruft sich auf Paragraph 100 G, das ist die Strafprozessordnung und da...
In Deutsch?
Ja, das heißt, begründet bestimmte Tatsachen den Verdacht, dass jemand als Täter oder Teilnehmer bla bla bla Straftat hat erhebliche Bedeutung. Und da ist in der Tat natürlich jetzt, da ist jetzt nicht drin definiert, was die speichern müssen, sondern nur unter welchen Voraussetzungen die Polizei es abfragen darf. Diese Vorratsanspeicherung ist ja erst einmal gekippt, das war 113 und befindet sich jetzt gerade, ja ist jetzt Gegenstand öffentlicher Debatte kann man sagen, weil es natürlich Leute gibt, die die wieder haben wollen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Ja, also vielleicht nur nochmal, damit das auch klar ist, diese Trennung, was in Dresden passiert ist, da ist die Polizei einfach aufgrund der Strafprozessordnung, also polizeilicher Gesetzgebung, dazu in der Lage zu dem Operator zu gehen und zu sagen, wir wollen einfach mal diese Daten, die du da gespeichert hast, sowieso. Also da geht die Polizei nicht vorhin, sagt jetzt mal bitte einschalten, irgendwie bestimmte Daten speichern und das ist auch nicht so, dass ein Gesetz sagt, jetzt diese Datensätze müssen erhoben werden, damit wir sie später abfragen können, sondern das ist einfach nur alles, was da so rumliegt beim Operator und was Verkehrsdaten sind, kann die Polizei dann abholen.
Also im Prinzip sagen, also da ist irgendwas passiert, die Polizei denkt sich kurz danach, also wie genau dieses kurz danach, beim besten das wissen wir nicht genau, aber kurz danach sagt die Polizei, okay, jetzt gebt uns doch einfach mal alles, was ihr zu diesem Zeitpunkt da habt.
Ja, das ist aber vergleichsweise ungewöhnlich, wenn man sich sozusagen den Regelkatalog anguckt, der ansonsten bei dem Telekommunikationsgesetz festgelegt ist. Es ist zwar so, mit dem TKG hat sich das Paradigma grundlegend geändert. Früher war es so, Staatsanwaltschaft geht zum Richter, Richter macht einen Beschluss und dann wird quasi dem Netzbetreiber gesagt, du musst uns jetzt das und das geben. Heute ist das Gesetzwerk und die technische Installation so konstruiert, dass der Netzbetreiber selbst nicht wissen darf, wer abgehört wird. Das ist dann sozusagen mit der These, der könnte ja seine Kunden warnen und so fort. Und das heißt, der hat automatisierte Schnittstellen zur Verfügung zu stellen, die natürlich nach Krafttechnischer Wassersuppe und dagegen gesichert sein sollen, dass sie missbraucht werden. Aber beispielsweise automatisierte Abfrage, wer ein Anschlussinhaber ist, da gibt es einfach eine Schnittstelle für die Behörden und da hat der Netzbetreiber auch keinen Einfluss drauf, was da passiert.
Also wir sagen, die Polizei sagt, hackt in ihren Rechner so, sag doch mal bitte, wer hinter dir nochmal Blabla steckt und dann spuckt das System jetzt einfach aus und jetzt der Netzbetreiber nochmal extra sozusagen was zu sagen hat.
Richtig, ja. Das ist, also geht völlig online und völlig ohne, dass da jetzt irgendwie der Netzbetreiber noch irgendwas tun müsste. Das hat doch keiner gehackt. Na ja, das weiß man halt nicht.
Es gibt ja auch Leute, die hacken und die genießen das dann einfach.
Die sagen einfach, ok, weiß man nicht so genau. Na schön, ok, jetzt haben wir also festgestellt, was in Dresden jetzt gerade passiert ist, ist sozusagen, wie ich sag mal, normale Polizeiarbeit, wie auch immer man das dann genau beschreiben will.
Schon ein bisschen ungewöhnlich, weil die Schwere der Straftaten, die begangen ist. Die Frage ist ja, wie stellt man die denn fest, wenn man so eine Maßnahme anortet, bevor Straftaten begangen sind? Also wir hatten ja andere Fälle in Deutschland, wo beispielsweise dieser, bei Oldenburg, wo diese Jugendlichen diesen Holzklotz auf die Autobahn geschmissen haben und wo man dann gesagt hat, das war ein heimtückischer Mord und wir wollen jetzt wissen, was da ist. Und dann sind die auch aufs Zähnungsprogramm und haben auch, ich hab die genau zahl ich im Kopf, aber über 100.000 Daten sind sie jedenfalls auch abgefragt, um zu gucken, wer war da in der Umgebung zum Zeitpunkt der Tat, aber da gab es immerhin den Mord. Bei Dresden war das ein bisschen komplizierter und insofern schon ungewöhnlich.
Ja, also das ist halt immer so eine Abwägungsfrage, bei welcher Art von Straftat wird sowas eben, ist das berechtigt oder nicht und das wird eben, wie wir schon vorhin erwähnt haben, immer weiter aufgeweicht. Man kann sich schon fragen, ist es denn gerechtfertigt, nur weil da, sag ich mal, so ein bisschen Widerstand gegen Polizei oder ähnliches da war, oder es ein bisschen zu Rangeleien gab, muss man deswegen zu dieser Vollüberwachung einer ganzen Stadt greifen?
Ja, aber da wollte ich auch so sagen, dass das kleinere Übel aus eurer Perspektive ist, weil diese Geschichte von vor zwei Jahren, die da aufgetaucht ist mit den zwei Millionen Sachen oder Leuten, das ist ja aufgrund der Vorratsdatenspeicherung passiert, weil die gab es damals noch. Das heißt, du hast jetzt gerade erklärt, die Polizisten sind in einem aktuellen Fall hingegangen und haben gesagt, gib mal alles, was ihr habt, was ist denn der Unterschied zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wie funktioniert denn die?
Ja, also die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist etwas, was eingeführt wurde vor einigen Jahren, ich weiß nicht mehr was, Anfang 2009 oder 2008, also irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren wurde es ins Gesetz geschrieben, Paragraf 113a und b des Telekommunikationsgesetzes ist gekommen auf Druck seitens der EU, da gab es eine EU, eine Direktive oder Richtlinie dazu jedenfalls, dass es in allen Ländern umgesetzt werden muss. Und da ist es ganz anders, da geht es nicht darum, dass Daten, die sowieso schon da sind, dass man die dann nachher abgreift als Polizei, wenn man Glück hat sind die halt da, dann nimmt man sie nicht, wenn keine da sind hat man Pech gehabt, sondern da macht man das ganz, dreht man das um, sondern man sagt sozusagen, die gesamte Bevölkerung oder zumindest alle Teilnehmer von Telekommunikationsnetzen sind unter Generalverdacht und wir speichern mal auf Vorrat, im deutschen Fall für sechs Monate lang, sämtliche Verkehrsdaten dieser Telekommunikationsteilnehmer und da ist auch ganz genau spezifiziert, um was es geht, was da alles zu speichern ist und diese ganzen Daten muss dann jeder Anbieter von Telekommunikationsdiensten speichern, bevorraten, nur für den Fall, dass dann innerhalb von sechs Monaten mal irgendeine Polizei oder ähnliche Behörde des Staates sagt, ja wir hätten da gerne mal Daten gehabt. Also da werden dann wirklich, wenn man sich das vorstellt, wie viele Telefone, das betrifft ja nicht nur Mobiltelefonie, es betrifft Telefonnetze, das Internet, Mobiltelefonnetze, mobile Internetnutzung und so weiter. Diese ganzen Daten werden bevorratet und können dann auf Bedarf angefordert werden. Und das erfreulicherweise ist das dann durchs Bundesverfassungsgericht gekippt worden. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die entsprechenden Paragrafen inzwischen für nichtig erklärt und damit stehen sie zwar noch im Gesetz, aber sind nicht mehr in Kraft.
Okay, sind nicht mehr in Kraft, gibt es ja gerade in der Diskussion, ich war gerade ganz zerschott in der Nachricht, haben wir gerade gehört, okay, die EU debattiert gerade, ob man möglicherweise die Waffengesetze mal verschärfen sollte. Das ist ja fast schon ein Fortschritt, weil normalerweise heißt es ja immer, wir sollten noch mal hier irgendwie mehr überwachen. Das ist ja auch gerade in dem Fall so, also über Vorratsansprechung wurde ja auch gerade wieder gesprochen, wir brauchen mehr Überwachung und noch Gefährderdateien und weis der Geier was. Steht das gerade jetzt noch mal an, dass wir sozusagen die wieder bekommen oder sind wir da noch im Moment raus?
Ja, es gibt da schon ein starkes Drängen danach.
Ich würde sagen, reaktionäre Politiker sind da immer dahinter her. Bei jedem, egal was passiert, irgendwo wird irgendeine Straftat begangen, die irgendwo in der Brosse ist und dann wird sofort wieder in den Ring geworfen. Ja, aber mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung hätten wir da irgendwie was dagegen tun können. Das ist sehr bedauerlich, dass wir diese Diskussion immer wieder und immer wieder haben. Wir hängen halt jetzt im Moment in der Luft. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat Gott sei Dank eben diese Paragraphen für nichtig erklärt und damit sind sie erstmal vom Tisch. Das heißt, es wird de facto heute im Moment gerade keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung gemacht. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es immer noch die EU-Richtlinie, die es vorschreibt. Ich glaube, die EU hat inzwischen ein Verletzungsverfahren gegen Deutschland eingeleitet, weil es in Deutschland noch nicht umgesetzt ist in ein nationales Gesetz, bzw. halt wieder rausgenommen wurde. Und die Politik, respektive der Gesetzgeber, ist sozusagen berufen, irgendwas zu tun. Und was da genau passieren wird, das steht noch offen, aber Forderungen sind genug da, eben wieder eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung einzuführen.
Es ist jedenfalls nicht so, dass sich die Regierung über ihren Einfluss im Europäischen Parlament dafür einsetzt, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf Europa weiter abzuschaffen, was ja in der Theorie gab es ein Verfahren vom Europäischen Gerichtshof, wo andere Länder das versucht haben, aber da hat man auch noch keine Ahnung.
Da blüht uns noch was, weil wir noch diese anderen spannenden Themen haben, also das mit dem Imseacatcher und den semi-passiven Dingern, die da freundlich konditioniert sind und die inhaltliche Überwachung. Ganz kurz zum Abschluss dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung, eine Sache wollte ich noch sagen, Malte Spitz, sollte noch erwähnt werden, das war der grüne Politiker, der hat sich von der Telekom seine Vorratsdaten, Speicherungsdaten erklagt. Und bei der Zeit glaube ich gab es eine Visualisierung. Also wenn ihr jetzt die ganze Zeit zugehört habt und euch gefragt habt, was Vorratsdaten, Verkehrsdaten, wie soll das aussehen, da kann man das wirklich sehen. Da gibt es eine schöne Animation, da kann man sich das mal angucken. Da wisst ihr ganz genau, was man daraus absehen kann. Und das ist schon eine ganze Menge. Gibt es jetzt vom Club eine Position, wo ihr sagt, wir wollen entweder überhaupt gar nichts gespeichert wird oder wir wollen das vielleicht ein bisschen was oder...
Eine verdachtlose Speicherung von Telekommunikationsdaten hat nicht zu erfolgen. Also ganz klar nicht. Natürlich können wir nicht dagegen angehen, wenn es einen richtigen Beschluss gibt. Und wenn jemand verdächtigt wird, Straftaten nach Katalog im 100a, ist das nebenbei bemerkt, ist die Liste dieser besonders schweren Straftat, auch wenn die schon ganz schön lang ist. Da kann man natürlich sagen, naja gut, wenn da jemand eine Straftat begeht und dann wird er abgehört, um ihn dazu zu überführen, da kann man schwer was gegen tun. Aber, dass verdachtlos gespeichert wird und dann noch nicht mal, weder technisch noch juristisch, richtig sichergestellt ist, dass solche Daten nicht in fremde Hände fallen, das kann es nicht sein.
Okay, aber ich wollte es noch mal klar machen, weil ich glaube, dass viele Leute immerhin das sozusagen beide Extremen verstehen. Ihr seid nicht dagegen, dass Telekommunikationsmittel überhaupt gar nicht benutzt werden, um Verbrecher ein Ding festzumachen, sondern ihr seid dagegen, dass das von Verdachtslos halt gespeichert wird.
Es gibt zwei Dinge. Das eine ist eben, was Andy gesagt hatte, das Verdachtslose speichern, das andere ist halt immer die Verhältnismäßigkeit. Also ich weiß nicht, wer auf die Idee kommt, dass das Auswerten von 300.000 Personen, 800.000 Datensätze, 2 Millionen Datensätze, dass es in irgendeiner Art und Weise verhältnismäßig ist, über die Straftaten, die wir da reden. Da reden wir über, wie viele Täter sollen da ermittelt werden? 1, 2, 3, 4, eine Handvoll. Und dafür überwachen wir 300.000 Menschen. Wo ist da die Verhältnismäßigkeit?
Okay, ihr könnt übrigens, wenn ihr euch dazu äußern wollt, auch gerne hier anrufen. 0331 77 97 21 0 ist die Nummer. Falls ihr denkt, ach nee, wir brauchen noch viel mehr Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder vielleicht gar nichts, könnt ihr gerne heute ihre Meinung dazu sagen. Solange ihr euch überlegt, ob ihr das machen wollt, wollte ich hier zu dem zweiten großen Punkt auf unserer Liste kommen. Das ist der sogenannte IMSI Catcher, der möglicherweise auch in Dresden zum Einsatz gekommen sein könnte. Das weiß man nicht, aber das ist auf jeden Fall eines dieser Werkzeuge, die man zur Mobiltelefonsüberwachung benutzen kann. Was ist das? Was macht der? Kann ich mir den auch selber basteln?
Ja, das kann man definitiv. Worum geht es dabei? Zunächst mal vielleicht die Begrifflichkeit. IMSI ist die International Mobile Subscriber Identity. Das ist so etwas wie die Seriennummer der SIM-Karte. Das heißt eine eindeutige Nummer, die deinem Mobilfunkvertrag zugeordnet ist. Und die mit deiner Telefonnummer assesiert ist. Und das handelt sich um ein Gerät, was eine Basisstation vorgaukelt. Das heißt simuliert. Man startet dieses Gerät, es verhält sich wie eine normale Funkzelle des Netzbetreibers, ist aber keine. Man bringt dann die Telefonen dazu, in diese Zelle hineinzuwechseln, in diese falsche Zelle. Und dann weiß man natürlich, welche Telefone in der Umgebung sind. Diese Telefone suchen sich immer das stärkste Signal, die beste Zelle. Und wenn man also vorgaukelt, man sei die beste Zelle, und man sei die Telekom oder Vodafone oder einer dieser Netzbetreiber eben, dann werden die Telefone in der Umgebung dann alles sagen, eine starke Zelle, da buchen wir uns jetzt mal ein.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle eine ganz kurze Anmerkung machen zu, wir reden hier die ganze Zeit über GSM-Telefonie, wir reden jetzt über Funkzellen und können das nicht ganz genau erklären, aber es gibt ja schon viele andere, ältere Chaosradios, wo das genau passiert. Also wenn ihr euch das noch mal genau raufhelfen müsst, könnt ihr das gerne hören, chaosradio.de, da gibt es die ganzen alten Folgen. Chaosradio ccc.de Das auch, aber ich glaube, das andere funktioniert. Egal, ihr wisst Bescheid, könnt da hingehen. Und so, also kurz gesagt, ein Handy, wenn ich das anmache, bucht sich das, heißt sagen, in eine Zelle ein, das heißt irgendwo steht ein Funkmast und da kommuniziert das Handy mit. Ich nehme jetzt so einen Imseacatcher mit und dann denkt mein Handy, okay, das ist die Zelle. Das fragt mich natürlich, Moment mal, wenn ich normalerweise in einem WLAN kommuniziere, dann wird doch irgendwie sichergestellt, dass ich mit der richtigen Gegenstelle kommuniziere. Wieso kriegt denn das Mobiltelefon nicht mit, dass ich jetzt gerade mit jemandem kommuniziere, der überhaupt gar nicht zum Mobilfunkbetreiber gehört?
Also das liegt an einer Eigenart des GSM-Protokolls. Da ist quasi ein Fehler geschehen, kann man sagen. Bei der Erstellung des Protokolls, andere sagen, da ist kein Fehler gestehen, sondern das wurde absichtlich so gemacht, die sogenannte einseitige Authentifizierung. Das heißt, wenn ein Mobiltelefon sich beim Netz anmeldet über die Luftschrittstelle, also über einen Funkzellenmast, kann das Netz sehr genau und auch eindeutig überprüfen, ob das Mobiltelefon das behauptet, eine bestimmte INSI zu haben, das heißt, eine bestimmte Rufnummer zu haben, die einer INSI dann auch zugeordnet ist. Das ist cryptografisch überprüfbar quasi. Es gibt aber keinen Mechanismus andersrum, dass das Telefon auch feststellen kann, ob der Funkzellenmast, der behauptet zuständig zu sein, auch tatsächlich zum Netzbetreiber gehört. Das haben sie irgendwie vergessen, kommt vor. Man muss aber auch vielleicht sagen, der INSI Catcher ist noch die preiswerteste Variante unter den Gerätschaften, die die Behörden zur Verfügung stellen. Man kann damit auch noch eine Sache machen, die noch nicht erwähnt wurde. Nicht nur, dass die Telefon sich da einbuchen und dann hat man ihre INSI, sondern man kann das auch, das ist in Brockdorf und in anderen bei Demonstrationsgeschichten geschehen, wenn sich da so 5000 Teilnehmer irgendwo befinden, man schaltet so ein Ding an mit einer entsprechenden Sendeleistung, dann buchen die sich alle ja in das Gerät ein. Das heißt, sie sind nicht mehr im Netz, sind auch nicht mehr anrufbar. Und wenn man dann das Gerät wieder ausschaltet, versuchen sich 5000 Mobiltelefone gleichzeitig wieder im Funknetz einzumelden, was auch daran scheitert, dass da die Lastverteilung nicht immer so funktioniert, wie man das euch mal vorgestellt hat, weil das kein Fall ist, der vorgesehen wurde, dass da 5000 Leute auf einmal ihr Telefon quasi anschalten. Das heißt, da gibt es Probleme, das nennt man dann technisch allerdings nicht ein Problem, sondern man nennt das eine Möglichkeit, nämlich die Null of Service, also die Verfügbarkeit des Services einzuschränken. Das kann ja auch ein Feature sein, wenn man das sozusagen als Polizeiseite betrachtet. Keiner kann anrufen, es gibt keine Zeugen, keiner kann einen Anwalt herbeirufen. Man kann keiner kann Bilder senden vielleicht von Dingen, die gerade geschehen. Also man muss ja immer die Perspektive betrachten. Für die einen ist es ein Problem, für die anderen ist es ein tolles Feature.
Ja gut, ob ich da jetzt so weit gehen würde, ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Aber was vielleicht noch relevant ist bei dieser ganzen Frage, warum hat man das vergessen? Das ist ganz einfach. Das ist entwickelt worden und man hat grundsätzlich immer die Sicherheit des Netzanbieters berücksicht, aber nie die Sicherheit des Anwenders. Der Anwender, wen interessiert das? Wen interessiert dieser Kunde? Der sollte völlig zahlen und den Mund halten. Der Netzbetreiber muss sicher davor sein, also um einfach Rechnungen stellen zu können und seine Dienste nachweislich, dass sie genutzt wurden, muss der Netzbetreiber feststellen können, ob dieser Teilnehmer, der behauptet, ein bestimmter Teilnehmer zu sein, ob das tatsächlich diese SIM-Karte und dieses Telefon ist. Dafür muss ein Mechanismus da sein. Sonst gibt es Missbrauch, sonst gibt es Betrug und Leute, die auf fremder Gründen telefonieren usw. Um das auszuschließen, hat man technische Maßnahmen in das GSM-System eingebaut. Aber irgendwie Dinge, die dem Schutz des Anwenders dienen.
Man könnte es aber auch noch zugute halten, in 3G, also in der Weiterentwicklung des GSM-Standards ist jetzt auch eine Netzautentifizierung vorgesehen. Insofern ist das schon eingestanden, dass das ein Problem war.
Ich habe aber auch an sich Jahre später hat man dann doch mal das System verbessert, nicht wahr? Und dann hat man es auch gleich so verbessert, dass man sich wieder eine Lücke eingebaut hat. Eine Blöde, ist aber auch ärgerlich. Und zwar, wir sind jetzt hier in der Technik, ich werde noch den einen Satz erwähnen. Nämlich, wenn so ein Telefon sich versucht, auf 3G, also dem neuen Mobilfunksystem einzubuchen, auch als UMTS bekannt, dann kann eine 3G-Zelle, bevor sie sich automatisiert hat, kann sie sagen, ach schalt doch mal auf dieses alte GSM um. Und dann habe ich natürlich wieder die Probleme von GSM.
Ja, aber es gibt Mobiltelefone, die kann man dazu zwingen, nur im 3G zu bleiben.
Das glaubst du deinem Telefon?
Ja, das habe ich ausprobiert mit einem Monitorgerät.
Okay, ich habe aber auch, also ich habe jetzt nur Wikipedia geklickt im Vorfeld, aber da habe ich eben gelesen, dass diese Authentifizierungsmechanismus bei UMTS auch optional ist. Also der Betreiber muss den nicht anmachen.
Das ist so meines Kenntnisses nach nicht wirklich korrekt. Ja, es gibt bestimmte Konstellationen, wenn man sehr alte SIM-Karten in neuen Telefonen hat und so, aber da, ne, ne, ne.
Also generell ist UMTS sozusagen eine gute Idee, könnte man sagen.
Es ist besser, also aus Sicherheitsaspekten, die den Teilnehmer, die Sicherheit des Teilnehmens vor falschen Basisstationen beispielsweise, gesagt hat, ist es besser, aber nicht wirklich gut.
Na, es ist aber insofern besser, dass die Algorithmen, die eingesetzt werden, zur Verschlüsselung deutlich höheren Standard und deutlich technische, teurere Ausstattung, aufwändigerer Ausstattung für einen Angreifer erfordern. Aber hier reden wir jetzt gerade nur von Angriffen auf die Luftschnittstelle. Was die netzseitige Überwachung betrifft, also auch das, was in Dresden passiert ist, da gibt sich GSM und UMTS gar nichts.
Okay, das ist klar zu sagen. Wenn ich zum Anbieter gehe, dann sitze ich immer direkt an der Quelle, egal was der macht. Okay, jetzt muss ich mal kurz sortieren. Also IMSI Catcher gibt es. Genau, wir haben gerade schon festgestellt. Also man kann damit quasi einfach allen Telefonen, die da gerade in der Nähe sind, verbieten zu telefonieren, weil sie dann beschäftigt sind, sich wieder einzuloggen, wenn man den IMSI Catcher wieder ausmacht. Das kann man so lange machen, bis keiner mehr Bock hat. Dann kann man sozusagen, was kann man damit eigentlich machen? Also was habe ich denn für noch?
Es geht um die Identifikation der IMSIs und mit den IMSIs wiederum kann man die Teilnehmer identifizieren. Also wenn man wissen will, wer sich an einem Ort befindet und man hat die IMSIs, mit den IMSIs kann man sich aus der Netzbetreiberdatenbank die Rufnummern holen und über die Rufnummern dann entsprechend auch die Teilnehmerdatensätze, sprich das, was ich vorhin schon mal erwähnte, diese Schnittstelle, die Vorhandnisse, automatisierte Abfrage, das ist dann die Daten, die auch nach Gesetz erfasst werden müssen, Name, Vorname, Geburtsdatum, Anschrift und so fort.
Okay, das heißt, da habe ich dann diesen Punkt, wo ich dann nicht mehr hingehen muss zum Betreiber und sagen muss, mach mal Funkzahlenauswertung, sondern ich besorge mir quasi selber die anwesenden Rufnummern und frage dann automatisch ab, wer da war und habe dann schon mal einen Überblick.
Richtig, ja, das sind Möglichkeiten. Es gibt andere Dinge, wo man im Secature einsetzt, vielleicht mal ganz kurz die gängigen Fälle. Der eingängige Fall ist, dass man zum Beispiel nicht weiß, welche SIM-Karte oder was für ein Telefon eine zu überwachende Person benutzt. Also gerade wenn ich jetzt ein Krimineller bin und ich weiß, mit Telefonen wird viel überwacht und so, dann werde ich wohl kaum ein Telefon verwenden, was auf mich registriert ist oder was irgendwie mit mir assoziiert ist, sondern ich werde irgendwo halt ein Gebrauchtes mit einer gebrauchten Prepaid Sim, die noch auf jemand anders registriert ist oder irgendwelche solchen Sachen werde ich halt benutzen. Oder jeden Tag ein anderes Telefon verwenden, lauter solche Dinge, je nachdem wie paranoid man da ist. Und dann ist es sozusagen der Polizei oder der überwachenden Behörde nicht klar, was ist das jetzt, welche Telefonnummer benutzt der überhaupt, was für eine SIM-Karte benutzt der und deswegen können sie dann keine anderen Überwachungsmaßnahmen bei dem Netzbetreiber anträgen, weil sie wissen ja gar nicht, auf wen sie da überwachen sollen. Und dann benutzt man so einen IMSI-Catcher einfach, um herauszufinden, was für eine IMSI, also welche Identität benutzt dieser Mensch da gerade, um dann wieder zum Operator zu gehen und weiter zu überwachen. Das ist also ein ganz gängiges Einsatzszenario.
Aber wie mache ich das sozusagen? Ich kann ja nicht hingehen und sagen, okay IMSI-Catcher, catch mal das Telefon dort drüben.
Ja, doch ungefähr. Also wenn die Polizei beispielsweise eine Situation beobachtet und sie sieht die Leute telefonieren, weiß aber nicht die Rufnummern, dann können die sich in der Tat mit dem Geräte hinstellen. Sie müssen auch relativ weit ran bei einem IMSI-Catcher. Also 800 Meter ist so das technische, im städtischen Bereich, wo es aufhört dann effektiv zu sein.
Aber 800 Meter ist ja schon irgendwie gar nicht viel.
Genau. Ja, das ist das Maximum.
Aber was man da dann macht, ist man verfolgt diese Person. Also man, was weiß ich, der ist erst zu Hause, man sieht ihn da telefonieren, man weiß nicht, was er benutzt. Dann macht man da einmal kurz einen IMSI-Catcher an, sammelt alle IMSIs in der Umgebung ein, dann fährt er auf Arbeit, dann macht man das gleiche nochmal. Oder fährt er eben auch mit daher. Genau. Also man macht halt so zwei, drei solche Messungen und dann schaut man halt, welche Nummern tauchen bei allen drei Messungen auf. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit sagt, spätestens nach drei, vier Messungen weiß ich dann, wer das war.
Ich verstehe, also die gute alte Fußarbeit ist dann doch ein bisschen involviert. Okay, dann kann ich mit dem Imseacatcher herausfinden, wer womit telefoniert. Und was wir damit noch anfangen, das klären wir gleich. Ich muss jetzt erstmal kurz was erledigen. Chaos Radio heute, wie ihr hören könnt, zu Gast sind Andy Müller-Maguhn und Harald Welte von Chaos Computer Club und es geht heute um Mobilfunktelefonüberwachung und wir haben schon mal geklärt, was eine Funkzellenauswertung ist. Da werden einfach sogenannte Verkehrsdaten abgriffen beim Betreiber direkt. Reden haben über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung geredet, warum das, also wie man das macht, wann man das macht und ob das eine coole Idee ist und sind eher so zum Schluss gekommen ist. Nein, reden jetzt gerade über IMSI Catcher, haben da schon festgestellt, okay, man kann das benutzen, um rauszukriegen, wer mit einem bestimmten Telefon telefoniert. Jetzt habe ich, wie gesagt, vorher Wikipedia geklickt, gelesen, man kann den IMSI Catcher tatsächlich auch dazu benutzen, um zumindest einer einzelnen Person vorzugaukeln, das Telefon funktioniert ganz normal, also quasi man kann seine Telefonate durchreichen. Weil wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist doch, wenn ich einen IMSI Catcher anmache, buchen sich die ganzen Telefone ein, aber dann ist der nicht im Netz, das heißt dann, also das Telefon funktioniert einfach nicht.
Der Begriff IMSI Catcher ist, muss man mal sehen, der stammt sozusagen aus der Frühzeit der Geschichte, wo vergleichsweise einfache Geräte den Polizeidienststellen und den Nachredendiensten angeboten wurden, um das Problem der Teilnehmeridentifizierung, das war tatsächlich das primäre Ziel zu ermöglichen. Mittlerweile gibt es noch zwei weitere Arten von Anlagen, die hier erwähnt werden müssen, damit man das im Kontext versteht. Das eine sind tatsächlich reine passive Abhöreinrichtungen. Das sind also Geräte, die hören wirklich nur zu, die senden überhaupt nicht und die entschlüsseln mit den mathematischen Müssen, vielleicht dann mit etwas viel Computing Power, sag ich mal, also mit FPGAs, das sind so schnelle Prozessoren, die darauf optimiert sind, diese spezifische Kryptographie zu brechen. Das heißt, das ist so bei den Nachrichtendiensten, bei anderen, wenn es darum geht, dass das Target, also der Mensch, der abgehört wird, absolut nicht wissen soll, dass das passiert, im Botschaftenbereich und so fort, wenn man da wirklich auch was riskiert. Den Polizeidienststellen muss man sagen, ist das aber ein bisschen egaler, sondern die benutzen das, was man dann semi-passiv nennt. Das heißt, das sind Geräte, die hören schon im Wesentlichen zu und intervenieren dann, wenn es darum geht, dass sie irgendeine Situation ermöglichen wollen. Beispielsweise ein Gerät von 3G auf 2G zu switchen, beispielsweise im Sie nicht nur in Erfahrung zu bringen, sondern damit auch irgendwas zu machen, zum Beispiel das Telefon klingeln zu lassen oder irgendetwas. Wenn man so ein Gerät hat, dann kann man komplett simulieren, die Netzzelle zu sein, kann mit dem Telefon machen, was man will. Ich habe hier zufällig so eine Bedienungsanleitung von so einem Gerät vor mir, wo dann eben auch diese ganzen Features, dass man Gespräche abfangen kann, dass man die Gespräche rejekten kann, also dass jemand bekommt einen Anruf und dann wird dem Anrufer quasi simuliert, der hätte ihn jetzt weggedrückt, bis hin dazu, dass das Telefon überhaupt keine Anrufe, keine Nachrichten bekommt oder dass man Nachrichten, also eingehende Kurznachrichten, abändert, auch abgehende Kurznachrichten, dass die in dem Gerät quasi abgefangen werden.
Ganz kurze Punkte, die ich eigentlich erst mal nur wissen wollte, ist, dass dieses Gerät agiert, also der schöne Begriff ist doch Man in the Middle sozusagen, also ich habe mein Handy an, ich bin in so einem Imseacatcher semi-passiv irgendwie eingeloggt und ich kann ganz normal mein Telefon benutzen und ich merke das quasi nicht.
In einem rein passiven Gerät ja, das hängt total davon ab, wie die Konfiguration des Gerätes ist, was das Gerät tun soll. Wenn es dich in Anführungszeichen nur abhören soll, dann merkst du davon erst mal nichts, außer dass du bei deinem Telefon, wenn du jetzt genau hingucken würdest, nämlich im Monitormodus, wenn es einen hat, dass du vielleicht siehst, oha, das ist zwar eigentlich ein UMTS-Telefon und hier gibt es auch UMTS-Netz, aber irgendwie bin ich hier doch in einem 2G-Netz, also wo eben auch andere Algorithmen zur Verschlüsselung eingesetzt werden, die sich einfacher brechen lassen, um das wiederum abzuhören.
Ja, aber gut, vielleicht nochmal etwas einfacher eingestiegen. Ja, wir haben also ein Gerät, die einfachste Stufe ist der Imseacatcher. Wir bringen diese Identität der Telefone in Erfahrung. So und was man da aber zunächst sieht, sind nur die Einbuchversuche der Telefone. Ja, sein Einbuchversuch. Und dann kann ich als derjenige, der sozusagen diese falsche Basisstation kontrolliert, respektive die Software, die das tut, kann ich sagen, den schicke ich mal wieder zurück aufs normale Netz, den will ich gar nicht. Oder ich kann sagen, hey, das ist ja mein Target, den lasse ich jetzt mal rein in meine Zelle. Und dadurch kann man dann eben so selektive Sachen machen. Und wenn jetzt das Telefon einer Person in meiner falschen Basisstation eingebucht ist, dann kann ich diese ganzen Angriffe machen, die Andy beschrieben hat. Also mit ausgehende Angriffe woanders hin umleiten oder SMS schicken, die gar nicht stimmen. Oder was weiß ich, da kommt eine eingehende SMS an und da steht dann drin Treffpunkt, diese Uhrzeit, dieser Ort. Und dann schreibe ich halt eine andere Uhrzeit in einen anderen Ort rein, um den irgendwie da abzugreifen oder so. Also das sind halt alles Möglichkeiten, die man da hat ab dem Punkt, wenn man dann solche Main-in-the-Mittel-Angriffe erfährt. Da hat man dann nicht nur die falsche Basisstation, sondern man hat dann auch noch ein falsches Telefon sozusagen, was dann gegenüber dem echten Netz sich wie das Telefon des angegriffenen verhält.
Und im Fall Dresden lässt sich nicht ausschießen, dass die Polizei eben ein solches Gerät eingesetzt hat, einfach mit der Konfiguration alle im SIS reinzulassen und auch entsprechend passiv dann, wenn man die einmal identifiziert hat, die Verkehrsdaten aus der Luft abzugreifen.
Das geht eben auch. Da gibt es eine Aussage dazu, meines Wissens nach im Sächsischen Landtag wurde, ich weiß nicht mehr wer es war, aber seitens der Polizei oder des entsprechenden Innenministeriums usw. wurde bestätigt, dass ein Imsycatcher eingesetzt wurde auch. Zunächst wurde es bestritten, so wie in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Ja, zunächst über Überwachung, wir haben noch nicht überwacht. Und dann sind es irgendwie ein paar Hundert, ein paar Tausend, ein paar Zehn Tausend, ein paar Hunderttausend Datensätze und auch Leute. Dann sagt man, oh man war ja selber überrascht von der Menge der Datensätze, die eigentlich angefallen sind. Es ist ja auch völlig unlogisch, das ist eine große Demonstration, das ist mitten in der Großstadt, da erwartet man ja nicht, dass da hunderttausend Telefone sind. Das ist ja völlig überraschend. Ja und dann, völlig überraschend hat sich dann herausgestellt, dass da, ach da war ja auch noch die andere Abteilung, mit der haben wir ja gar nicht gesprochen und die hatte ja auch ein Imsycatcher zufällig im Rucksack. Also das ist halt der Stand der Information im Moment, was sie genau gemacht haben mit dem Imsycatcher, wofür sie ihn eingesetzt haben, wie oft, wie lange, wie viel Daten dabei angefallen sind und so weiter. Das ist halt alles noch nicht öffentlich bekannt, noch nicht irgendwie, sag ich mal, an die Öffentlichkeit gelangt.
Warten wir mal ab, vielleicht kommt da noch was bei rum. Ich hab jetzt sozusagen ganz gut entwickelt, was da alles rausgekommen ist. So ich würde jetzt gerne, bevor wir mit dem Imsycatcher weitermachen, weil ich würde dieses, mit dem kann man sich das selber basteln, gerne noch mal genauer klären. Wir haben jetzt einen Anrufer, der tatsächlich dem Aufruf vorhin gefolgt ist, um zu sagen, Vorratsdatenspeicherung ja oder nein. Und die Meinung beim Club ist ja relativ klar. Nee. Und er sagt, und das finde ich jetzt ganz spannend, ich würde es gerne kurz halten, aber ich würde es tatsächlich gerne mal kurz auch wirklich machen. Der sagt nämlich, der Jan, er hat keinen Mist gebaut, warum soll er dann dagegen sein und ist jetzt am Telefon. Tag Jan.
Hallo.
Du findest es also total super, wenn alle Leute sechs Monate lang ihre Verkehrsdaten gespeichert kriegen. Und zwar weil?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht so intensiv mit dem Thema beschäftigt, was Pro und Contra betrifft, aber ich habe nichts verbrochen. Und wenn auch nur der Hauch einer Chance besteht, damit irgendeinen Terroristen und sei es die Chance einer von 300.000 oder einer von drei Millionen oder irgendeinen, der in seinem normalen Job was total Ehrenwertes macht, aber nachts irgendwo Kinderpornografie runterlädt, den zu erwischen, dann finde ich das in Ordnung. Und derjenige, der das mit den Kindern meinetwegen macht, der wird vielleicht nicht fünfmal am Tag sein Handy wechseln.
Okay, das ist sozusagen so eine ganz klassische Extremargumentation, die anda bringt. Bitte.
Ja, was soll ich dazu sagen? Also in Bezug auf die Kinderpornografie, das ist ja in der Tat auch das Argument, was es war schon in EU-Papieren von 1996. Es war gesagt, das ist das wunderbarste Argument, um öffentliche Zustimmung zu bekommen, weil gegen Kinderpornografie sind alle. Das ist also natürlich konsensual. Man muss aber auch mal ein bisschen sehen, worum reden wir hier. Da müssen wir jetzt in die Materie einsteigen. So geht es um Missbrauch von Kindern oder geht es um Betrachten von Bildern. Verhindert man tatsächlich, dass Kinder missbraucht werden, wenn man diejenigen verfolgt, die sich solche Bilder angucken? Und ist das auch eine valide Rechtfertigung, um jetzt gleich mal alle Daten der gesamten Bevölkerung in Bezug auf ihr Telekommunikationsverhalten zu speichern? Weil darüber reden wir bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Wir möchten jetzt nicht eine Diskussion über Pornografie und Kinderpornografie und was auch immer halten.
Aber wenn das Argument kommt, kannst du es ja nicht komplett...
Mir geht es um jegliche Straftaten.
Jegliche?
Ja, also wer eine Straftat begeht, dafür gibt es ja Gesetze. Ich stimme natürlich zu.
Aber da hat ja Goethe, also Entschuldigung, da muss ich aber unterbrechen, weil dazu hat Goethe wirklich das Wichtige gesagt, wenn man alle Gesetze studieren würde, dann hätte man ja gar nicht mehr die Zeit, sie zu übertreten und dagegen zu verstoßen. Also wirklich jede Gesetze, wow.
Also ich möchte mal kurz sagen, Jan, also deine Argumentation zu Ende geführt, ist ja der Punkt, dass du sagst, wenn jemand kein Verbrechen begangen hat, hat er ja vor einer Vorratssattenspeicherung nichts zu befürchten. Du meinst sozusagen, dass es keine negativen Einflüsse auf einen normalen Menschen hat, wenn eine Vorratssattenspeicherung stattfindet. Da gibt es, glaube ich, eine andere Ansicht.
Ja, also ich möchte nur ganz kurz, bevor ich noch auf andere Punkte komme, dann mal sagen, gut, Filesharing ist ein Verstoß gegen Urhebergesetz, ist damit eine Straftat. Das heißt also jeder, der irgendwie mal ein Musikstück kopiert, unsrechtenmäßig, wäre dann also demnach schon irgendwie da drunter.
Hat doch noch nie jemand gemacht.
Ja, gut, ansonsten ist halt das Problem, dass diese Daten halt Bewegungsprofile auch enthalten und sehr viel Information über die einzelnen Personen. Die Frage ist dann eben, wer kann da drauf zugreifen? Ja, solche Datenbestände, wenn die erstmal irgendwo liegen, da gibt es große Interessen. Da gibt es vielleicht mal einen korrupten Polizeibeamten, der es dann natürlich auch wieder sich strafbar macht, aber der die Daten für was anderes benutzt. Es gibt vielleicht kriminelle Leute, die sich Zugang zu diesen Daten verschaffen. Und es sind halt schon sehr persönliche Dinge. Ja, da weiß man halt, ist jetzt jemand, keine Ahnung, wenn es jetzt um die Politik geht, ist jetzt jemand irgendwie, war der in dem Bordell oder nicht um die oder die Uhrzeit? Ja, und dann kann man da wieder einen öffentlichen Skandal draus machen und irgendwie, was weiß ich, da sozusagen die politische Karriere von Leuten beenden, nur weil man weiß, dass sie in einem bestimmten Ort waren, so in einer bestimmten Uhrzeit.
Also man kann mit den Daten, die man bemerkt, auch noch ganz andere Sachen machen. Wenn man jetzt mal über Wirtschaftsspionage oder Methoden redet, um irgendwie Straftaten zu begehen. Es sind ja hochinteressante Daten, wer wann wo ist. Es gab einen Fall in Köln vor Jahren, wo ein Mitarbeiter einer Bank, der dafür zuständig war, Überwachungsvideos auszuwerten, ein Muster bei einer bestimmten Filiale entdeckt hatte. Das funktionierte so, dass die Leute da mal mit dem Auto vorfahren konnten. Es war so eine Drive-In-Filiale quasi. Und es gab so ein Muster, wie die Kunden sich verhalten haben. Die sind also mit ihrem Auto vorgefahren, den Schlüsselbund noch in der Hand, haben den auf einen Kontostandsdrucker gelegt, ihre Karte reingeschickt, sich einen Kontostand ausdrucken lassen, dann weiter zum Geldautomaten, im PIN-Code eingeben, sich ein bisschen Kohle gezogen und sind damit da weitergefahren. Und was der gemacht hat, war, mit einem fein mechanisch begabten Freund zum einen aufgrund der Überwachungsvideos nach Schlüssel erzeugt haben, aufgrund der hochauflösenden Videos, die er von den Schlüsseln hatten, und zum anderen aufgrund der Daten, wann die Leute das nächste Mal in der Filiale waren, mit wiederum einem kleinen Netzwerk von Kumpels, den Leuten die Wohnung ausgeräumt hat. Und das ist vielleicht mal so ein kleines Beispiel, was klar macht, dass so Daten, die anfallen, in sogenannten Überwachungsvorgängen noch lange nicht dazu da sind Sicherheit zu erhöhen, sondern im Gegenteil hochgradig gefährlich sind, um Straftaten zu begehen, also um Unsicherheit quasi auszubauen. Und wir reden hier davon, wenn wir wirklich alle Vorratsdaten, also alle Daten der Telekommunikationsvorgänger, dann weißt du, wer mit wem Kontakt hat, du kannst Beziehungen, wirtschaftliche Verflechtung, alles Mögliche analysieren. Und das ist nicht nur für konkurrierende Unternehmen hochinteressant, sondern auch in menschlichen Zusammenhängen. Und ich will nicht in einer Gesellschaft leben, wo ich nicht mehr weiß, wer was über mich weiß. Und das genau ist ja die Begründung von Datenschutz überhaupt gewesen, informationelle Selbstbestimmung, dass man gesagt hat, wenn Leute nicht mehr wissen, was andere über sie wissen, dann werden sie sich nicht mehr so verhalten, wie sie sich verhalten und werden auch ihre demokratischen Rechte zu protestieren, sich zu organisieren und sofort nicht mehr wahrnehmen. Und darum geht es.
Jan, siehst du möglicherweise ein, dass es da auch eine Gegenargumentation gibt?
Logisch, keine Frage. Und dass die Kontrollmechanismen, dass das verstärkt werden muss, also wenn ich jetzt habe das jetzt von der Demonstration in Dresden das erste Mal gehört, aber dass da natürlich ein Parlamentarier geben muss, der dort Einblick bekommt und nicht hingehalten wird, also das versteht sich von selbst. Also gleich ist es ja mit dem Geheimdienst, Ausschuss und so weiter und so fort.
Okay, also ich empfehle dir einfach noch mal den Anfang der Sendung zu hören. Da haben wir schon mal ganz genau erklärt, wie sicher Behörden diese Daten verwalten hier anfangen. Und einen Tipp, Jan, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Einen Tipp würde ich da auch noch geben, in eine Diskussion, die schon jahrelang geführt wird einzusteigen mit. Ich habe mich jetzt nicht so ausführlich damit beschäftigt, aber ich habe eine sehr extreme Meinung. Könnte man noch mal drüber nachdenken? So, hätten wir das also auch geklärt mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung? Gut, ihr könnt weiterhin noch anrufen. Wie gesagt, also die Diskussion läuft schon eine Weile und wenn man eine extreme Meinung hat, dann sollte man die schon auch gut begründen können. Finde ich zumindest machbar. Zurück zum Imseacatcher. Wir hatten festgestellt, was man mit alles machen kann und ihr hattet ganz am Anfang gesagt, man kann sich ja auch selber bauen. Jetzt ist es ja bei dem selber Bauen immer so ein Sache. Also theoretisch könnte man sich auch einen Space Shuttle selber bauen. Das macht nur keiner, weil es so super komplex ist. Wie einfach ist es denn wirklich so ein Ding zu machen?
Ja, das ist heutzutage total leicht. Ich bin selber ja sehr aktiv im Bereich Open-Source-Entwicklung zu GSM-Protokollen. Und hab tatsächlich also mir im Laufe der letzten Jahre eben Software dafür geschrieben. Jetzt nicht speziell für den IMSEE-Catcher. Aber in dem Moment, wo ich Software habe, die ein Mobilfunknetz implementiert, kann ich natürlich ein echtes Netz implementieren. Ich kann aber auch ein falsches Netz implementieren. Wenn ich ein falsches Netz habe, habe ich die falsche Basisstation. Da gibt es eine Reihe von, also drei von Projekten in letzter Zeit, die das ein bisschen öffentlicher machen. Zunächst bleibt mir historisch, ich glaube so 1994 herum ist die erste öffentlich bekannte Dokumentation von dem Imseacatcher und zwar eine Patentschrift der deutschen Firma Rode & Schwarz, die sogenannte Virtual Base Station, die virtuelle Basisstation. Da geht es also eben genau um diese Man in the Middle Angriff, den wir schon beschrieben haben, den sie da machen. Das heißt also, sei mal technisch bekannt, wie das funktioniert, öffentlich ist spätestens seit 1994, seitdem es dieses Patent gibt. Dann gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Firmen, diese ganze Sicherheitsindustrie, von der Andy von vorhin schon gesprochen hatte, die kommerzielle Geräte verkaufen in dem Bereich. Manche davon verkaufen das halt nur an Behörden, sag ich mal. Ja, weil die Frage ist, was sind das für Behörden? Und wenn es jetzt, was es sich der Pakistanische Geheimdienst hat, ist es dann auch eine legitime Behörde, die sowas gekauft hat. Die können das dann nach Deutschland mitbringen, können da irgendwelche Forschungen, also irgendwelche Spionage damit anstellen. So ist immer die Frage. Ja, nur Behörden heißt halt auch, naja, Behörden jedes Landes.
Die pakistanische Regierung ist ja zugleich ein schlechtes Beispiel. Die sind doch bei jedem Zweifel erhaben.
Ach so, ja, das wissen wir. Ja, deswegen habe ich ja dieses Beispiel gewähnt. Ja, können auch die amerikanischen Freunde ansprechen. Aber jedenfalls will ich mal gesagt haben, gut, es gibt eine Industrie, es gibt eine Branche, wo man die kaufen kann. Da gibt es seriösere Anbieter, da gibt es weniger seriöse Anbieter. Das heißt, wenn ich ein bisschen Geld auf der Tasche habe, dann kann ich mir so ein Ding auch einfach kaufen. Dann brauche ich nicht selber bauen. Hausnummer? Heutzutage, denke ich, ist man inzwischen im fünfstelligen Bereich angekommen. Vor ein paar Jahren musste man da schon noch so 100.000, 200.000 Euro irgendwie auspacken.
Aber wenn du jetzt über Nanozellen, Picozellen solltest du vielleicht auch noch reden. Das sind ja eigentlich auch BTS, also wie man sagt, Base Station Prinziper, die dasselbe machen und die nur entsprechend programmiert werden müssen.
Entschuldigung, Nanozellen bitte was?
Gleich. Diese Geldbeträge, die ich hier gesehen habe, das ist jetzt sozusagen die klassische Überwachungstechnologie-Anbieterindustrie, wo ich einfach hingehen kann, ich kaufe die irgendwie rundum glücklich Variante, ich kann nur Maus schubsen, ich weiß überhaupt nichts von der Technik, dann kann ich mir da was kaufen und das ist mit Schulung und allem drum und dran und dann funktioniert das. Ja, die Selberbau-Variante ist natürlich deutlich...
Auf die Behörde geeignet.
Richtig, auch ich, genau. Ja, jedenfalls wenn ich das selber bauen will, kann ich das deutlich leichter haben. Also ich kann mir Hardware kaufen, die inzwischen, sag ich mal, sich im Bereich von 1000 Dollar oder so bewegt, also was, was ich wirklich jedermann noch irgendwie leisten kann. Ja, das ist irgendwie zwei Smartphones, so ungefähr, vom Preis her. Also Hardware für den Betrag, dann benutze ich irgendwie Open-Source-Software, die für jedermann zur Verfügung steht, die muss ich noch ein bisschen richtig konfigurieren und muss noch hier und da ein bisschen was drehen, aber dann habe ich das Ganze.
Die gibt es aber auch schon.
Die gibt es schon, ja, das ist eben keine Imseacatcher-Software an sich, sondern es ist Software, die dir erlaubt, ein GSM-Netz zu betreiben. Da gibt es einmal das sogenannte Open-BTS-Projekt und auf der anderen Seite das Open-BSC-Projekt. Das sind beides Projekte, mit denen man sein GSM-Netz-Server betreiben kann. Und ein Imseacatcher, wie wir gerade erfahren haben, ist ja eigentlich nichts anderes als ein GSM-Netz, was nur sich falsch ausweist.
Also das hört sich jetzt an, wenn ich einen 1000 auf der Kante habe, dann hole ich mir so einen Teil, spiele ich Software drauf und dann geht es los. Jetzt ist es ja gerade bei Open-Source-Software so, dass es nicht immer so ganz einfach ist. Wie hoch muss denn der, also mein Fähigkeitswert sagen, also muss ich mich dann schon wirklich da reinknien? Oder ist es wirklich so irgendwie, ich klick mir so ein Ding im Shop und dann lese ich mir irgendwie drei How-To's im Internet durch und dann läuft es?
Naja, das kommt im Wesentlichen darauf an, so was für Know-How bringt man mit. Wenn ich jetzt mal sage, so ich bin irgendwie in der Fit, ich entwickele selber irgendwie Software, ich kenne Computersysteme, ich kenne mich ein bisschen mit Kommunikationssystemen aus, so in die Richtung, dann ist es natürlich nicht so super schwer. Dann würde ich sagen, bis es mal sauber funktioniert und getestet ist in ein paar Wochen oder so, jemand, der jetzt weniger Erkenntnisse mitbringt, der wird sicherlich einfach nur damit er weiß, muss erstmal verstehen, wie funktioniert dieses GSM Netz, was genau macht jetzt irgendwie so ein IMSI-Catcher, wie konfiguriere ich diese Software und so weiter, da würde ich dann schon sagen, es ist vielleicht im Monatsbereich, also ich sage mal im einstelligen Monatsbereich, was er da irgendwie an Aufwand hineinstecken muss.
Also ein Teil der Komplexität besteht sicherlich darin, dass man sich mal kurz einlesen muss, wie GSM tatsächlich funktioniert, also wie eben die Trennung der Frequenzbereiche, Organisationskanäle und so fort stattfindet, auch wie die Handoverprozeduren, also wie Telefone ihre Zellen wechseln und so fort, da muss man sich schon ein bisschen reinlesen. Und damit wollte ich auch ganz kurz noch einen Seitenschwenk eröffnen, nämlich abgesehen von der Variante, sich so eine kleine Zelle zu holen und sich die mit Open Software zu programmieren, gibt es auch noch die Variante des rein Passivens, erst mal zuhören, da gibt es Geräte, also kann man sich vorstellen wie ein Scanner, also wie ein Empfänger, der Vollprogrammierer ist, es gibt den sogenannten GNU Radio Entwicklungsstrang, das sind Geräte, die kosten zwischendurch auch so etwas 1500, 1200, ja, geht bei 1000 an inzwischen, gibt es auch billigere, bei 3000 Dollar, ja, und nächste Woche ist da ein Dollar dann ja eh, der US-Slot, die wird dann ja günstiger, und dann gibt es da auch schon teilweise Softwarekomponenten, Mit dem man zumindest da schon mal reinhorchen kann. Reinhorchen heißt jetzt nicht, sorry, klingt jetzt so, als wenn man dazuhören kann, kann man auch nicht, aber man kann sich dann schon mal das Protokoll angucken. Das heißt, man kann sich schon mal angucken, was in seiner Funktion so los ist.
Also als Vergleich sagen sie es, wie ein verschlüsseltes WLAN mitzuschneiden. Das heißt, du hast schon mal einfach alle Daten auf der Platte und dann kann man später mal gucken, was man damit macht.
Ja, es ist ja nicht alles verschlüsselt.
Ja, also es ist durchaus machbar. Das wurde ja auch inzwischen mehrfach demonstriert. Wir hatten am diversen ZTC-Kongressen dazwischen Vorträge und Demonstrationen, auch auf anderen Konferenzen in den USA im IT-Security-Bereich, ist das hinlänglich oft demonstriert worden, dass man sich nun echt mit extrem wenig Geld und wenig Aufwand irgendwie einen Imseacatcher selber bauen kann. Und das, was da passiert, ist ja nur, wie soll ich sagen, eine Demokratisierung dieser Technik und auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite eben einfach ein Mehrbewusstmachen, dass das geht. Das ist nicht so, dass jetzt erst seit ein, zwei Jahren diese Technik verfügbar ist. Die Technik ist seit, wie gesagt, mindestens 1994 verfügbar. Es ist nur so, dass jetzt jeder sich selber ein Bild davon machen kann und sich davon überzeugen kann, wie funktioniert das. Und auch schon vor, was weiß ich, schon vor zehn Jahren habe ich Gerüchte gehört, dass die britische Presse, also die Tabloids irgendwie in England durchaus Imseacatcher auf Prominente ansetzen. Also dass die schon damals Imseacatcher hatten, weil sie halt einfach vielleicht die nächste große Story über das Königshaus und die Affären ist halt einfach so viel mehr wert als diese 100.000 Euro, die man für den Imseacatcher ausgeben muss. Da kann man mal leicht so ein Gerät kaufen, um irgendwie die Königsfamilie abzuhören.
Das ist ja auch bei News of the World nebenbei, wer merkt durchaus noch, im Moment geht es ja um das Abhören der Voice-Mailboxen. Das war ein vergleichsweise technisch primitiver Angriff, aber auch da ist noch nicht ganz raus, ob da nicht auch GSM-Abhörmaschinen benutzt wurden. Also bei den Mörderunternehmen.
Ich halte mal fest, Imsy-Catcher selber machen, fällt in die Kategorie aufwändigeres, komplexeres Hobby, aber ist auf jeden Fall machbar, wenn man will.
Also vielleicht noch dazu...
Ja, so laubsige Arbeiten und GSM-Abhören, das...
Vielleicht noch dazu, also inzwischen ist es auch so, dass es einige Bachelor- und Masterarbeiten in dem Bereich gibt.
Man findet im Netz schon auch...
Nicht, dass in den Arbeiten wirklich was Neues sind, stünde, aber da kann man auch das Niveau sehen. Ein Informatikstudent, der eine Abschlussarbeit schreibt, wenn man dieses Niveau hat technisch, dann schafft man es in jedem Fall.
Okay, alles klar, wisst ihr Bescheid, wo ihr verstehen müsst, wenn ihr euch einen eigenen IMSEE-Catcher bauen wollt. So, dann haben wir jetzt also die Funkzellenauswertung, dann haben wir den IMSEE-Catcher. Aber der IMSEE-Catcher macht ja schon so ein bisschen, wie heißt das, ich vergesse es immer wieder, semi-passiv?
Der IMSEE-Catcher ist irgendwie so ein einfacher Begriff, aber das ist tatsächlich das Primitivste der Geräte. Man redet ansonsten von passiven oder semi-passiven.
Oder auch semi-aktiven.
Oder semi-aktiven Dingern. Die machen dann eben, also die reinen Passiven, das ist auf der einen Seite, dass es einen programmierbaren Empfänger hat, der die Signale entsprechend rausholt und sortiert. Man muss ja sehen, dass so ein Mobiltelefon, wenn man eins abhören will, unter Umständen mehrfach während eines Gesprächs, wenn es sich bewegt, die Funkzelle und damit auch die Frequenz wechselt. Und die muss man quasi hinterher schalten, damit man das Gespräch voll abhören kann. Und dann braucht man noch Gerätschaften, um das Ganze zu dekodieren, also zu entschlüsseln. Es gibt ja drei verschiedene Algorithmen, die im GSM eingesetzt werden, um die Sprache zu verschlüsseln. Und dann gibt es noch A5, also die fangen alle mit A5 an. A50 ist eigentlich kein Algorithmus, es ist nämlich keine Verschlüsselung. Muss man trotzdem erwähnen, gibt es immer noch Länder und Mobiltelefone, die das komischerweise unterstützen, auch wenn anderes behauptet wird. Dann gibt es der Dominant im Einsatz, würde ich sagen, der Dominant ist A52, oder?
Nein, A51 ist der gängige Algorithmus. Also es gibt mehrere Algorithmen, aber da kommen wir jetzt eben auch in die Inhalte hinein.
Genau, darauf wollte ich hinaus. Da sind wir ja auch. Fast schon Ende der Sendung, also halbe Stunde haben wir noch, aber jetzt gibt es das Leckerli, das Dessert. Inhaltliche Überwachung, also ich möchte nicht nur wissen, wer da wo wann mit wem telefoniert wird, sondern ich möchte verdammt nochmal auch wissen, was hat der gesagt?
Also der A5.1-Algorithmus ist technisch schon durch, kann man sagen.
Technisch schon durch heißt sozusagen, existiert noch, aber es kann jeder Bastler ihn knacken.
Richtig, ja.
Warte mal, ich hab halt noch kurz einen Schritt zurück. Entschuldigung, kurz einen Schritt zurück. Also ich muss ja sozusagen, bevor ich diese Daten entschlüssel, muss ich an die ran kommen. Da gibt's ja sozusagen, hab ich drei Wege. Ich kann einerseits über diesen MC-Catcher gehen, also beziehungsweise dieses wie auch immer geartete Gerät, was Geräte, was diese Daten mitschneiden kann.
Ja, sagen wir einen Interceptor.
Ein Interceptor. Okay, kein MC-Catcher, ein Interceptor. Ist der dann genauso leicht zu bauen? Ja klar, ich muss einfach nur die Base Station machen.
Noch leichter eigentlich. Passiv oder semi-passiv?
Passiv.
Okay, rein passiv ist es tatsächlich, kannst du genug Radio nehmen und musst ihn nur programmieren.
Okay, dann hab ich so eine Art, der schneidet einfach mit, was du gerade an den Sender befroren hast.
Also ein Gerät für 1000 US-Dollar und ein bisschen Software.
Vielleicht nochmal für die Leute, die da mehr dazu lesen wollen, die frei erhältliche Open Source Software, die man dafür nehmen kann für dieses rein Mithören, nennt sich Air Probe, also wie Air, also die Luft und Probe, ja die Sonde, genau. Die Hardware, um die es da geht, die wir ansprechen, ist zum Beispiel das USRP, das ist das Universal Software Radio Peripheral. Das ist ein Gerät, was man an USB anschließt und was eine Antenne hat. Und das Gerät zusammen mit dieser Radio Software und dieser Air Probe Software kann man dann eben benutzen dafür.
Also ich nehme Hardware und schneide den GSM-Funk quasi mit, das ist die eine Variante, dann kann ich natürlich zumindest auf Schadlichstelle auch immer wieder zum Anbieter gehen und sagen Alter, gib mal einen Halter.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das ist nicht...
Es geht erstmal nur darum, wie ich an den Halter rankomme. Das geht doch, oder?
Zum Netzbetreiber kannst du aber nur gehen, wenn du im Nachrichtendienst bist, in der Polizei, und nicht wenn du ein Hacker bist und deine Nachbar nachbehalten willst.
Wir haben ja die Sendung angefangen mit den Hacker. Ich würde schon gerne auch, dass wir wenigstens kurz dabei bleiben. Die müssen es aber vorher Bescheid sagen.
Also in den Netzen gibt es ja neben der Möglichkeit, die Verkehrsdaten und die erhobenen Daten in irgendeiner Form abzufragen, auch noch die sogenannten Lovel Interception, das heißt die Abhörmöglichkeiten, die vorgesehen sind, die setzen allerdings tatsächlich voraus, dass da gesagt wird, ok, dieser Teilnehmer wird abgehört, und dann wird immerhin in Echtzeit, also live quasi, werden die übertragenen Gespräche auch nochmal über eine Stelle, geschlossene Benutzungsgruppe im ISDN Netz, den Behörden dann übermittelt, um sie dort aufzuzeichnen.
Frage ist das sozusagen, die Polizei geht hin und sagt, wir möchten ab jetzt abhören? Das ist nicht wie dieses vollautomatische, ich frag mal eben abwärts in den Anschluss gehört, das muss schon sagen.
Also das ist auch wieder dieses richterliche Verfahren mit dem Vorbehalt, den wir vorhin ja...
Aber nicht bei den Nachrichtendiensten, da ist es kein richterliches Verfahren.
Das ist richtig, ja. Also gut, es gibt gesetzliche Anforderungen, warum, wer da hinkommen kann. Das sind die sogenannten berechtigten Stellen. Das ist auch ein bisschen das Vokabular hier mit reinzubringen. Also wir sprechen jetzt über die sogenannte Telekommunikations... Bedarfsträger ist auch Behörndeutsch. Im Gesetz steht die berechtigte Stelle. Wird auch in den ganzen technischen Richtlingen immer als BS bezeichnet, die berechtigte Stelle. Ja, die berechtigte Stelle kann also eben einer dieser Geheimdienste, die Polizei sein. Und was sehr interessant ist, was sie also alles geregelt haben zum Beispiel, ist, dass mehrere berechtigte Stellen gleichzeitig, und zwar bis zu drei gleichzeitig, können den gleichen abhören. Und die dürfen voneinander nicht wissen, dass sie alle den gleichen abhören.
Und Harald, du bist nicht auf dem letzten Stand. Das wurde erweitert. Das müssen jetzt fünf gleichzeitig abhören können ohne.
Ja, da hab ich wieder was verpasst. Es ist schon ein paar Jahre her, dass ich mir das alles durchgelesen hatte. Wir hatten da auch schon mal ein Chaosradio dazu gemacht, als es neu kam mit der TKÜV. Das sind also mehrere Stellen, die unanfänglich voneinander das gleiche Telefon abhören können und voneinander gegenseitig nicht wissen dürfen, dass die anderen abhören. So genau ist das alles geregelt. Da werden dann die Inhalte ausgeleitet. Das betrifft nicht nur die Gespräche, es betrifft genauso SMS oder E-Mails oder was auch immer man eben so tut, mit dem Telefon oder mit seinem Computer.
Das ist natürlich das Unaufwendigste, zumindest wenn das dann geklappt hat. Der dritte Fall, den ich mir aufgeschrieben habe, so stelle ich mir das zumindest vor, viele Leute haben ja Smartphones, also eher kleine Rechner als die alten Mobiltelefone. Da stelle ich mir vor, da könnte man einfach eine Software drauf spielen und dann damit mithören.
Da sind wir beim Thema Bundeszirianer oder die sogenannte Quellen-TKÜ. TKÜ für Telekommunikationsüberwachung, Quelle, weil das Telefon ist die Quelle der Kommunikation. Das hat man sich ausgedacht, weil die bösen Kriminellen und auch nicht Kriminellen, die haben sich ja erlaubt und erdreistet, Verschlüsselung einzusetzen. Also sowas wie um Gottes willen. Sie fangen an, ihre Kommunikation zu verschlüsseln. Und was müssen wir da machen? Wir müssen also Schadsoftware auf dem Endgerät installieren, um bevor der Verschlüsselungsvorgang aktiv wird in dem Gerät, die Daten noch abzugreifen.
Das ist also nachdem sie entschlüsselt wurden. Und das ist auch angefangen hat, dieses Problem erst in der Fläche tatsächlich ein Problem zu werden, durch Skype. Skype verschlüsselt zwar die Gespräche nicht so, dass Skype darauf kein Zugefetter, aber Skype ist eben keine in Deutschland beistutweise greifbares Unternehmen, das man mal so kurz dem Telekommunikationsgesetz unterstellen kann, weil die ja damit nicht mal Geld verdienen, sondern einfach nur Software im Netz verteilen.
Und Geld verdienen ist ja kein Punkt.
Na gut, geschäftsmäßig ist richtig. Aber der Punkt ist dann der, also die Quellen-TKÜ ist eigentlich schon Propagandabehördendeutsch. Im Gesetz heißt das ja nicht so, sondern das ist ja die Behauptung, dass man eben eine Telekommunikationsüberwachung an der Quelle machen würde. Da sind wir auch gleich wieder beim Bundesrujaner. Das ist nämlich dasselbe. Die technischen Dienstleister, wenn man jetzt im Netz danach googelt, dann sollte man nach Rimut Forensik Tools suchen. Und das ist auch eine Propagandalüge, weil Forensik heißt ja quasi Daten beweis-sicher zu erheben. Und das Problem bei so einem Projaner ist, dass man eben nicht mehr beweis-sicher sagen kann, welche Daten eigentlich durch den Verdächtigen in diesem Fall erstellt oder verarbeitet wurden und welche Daten durch den Trojaner da reingebracht wurden.
Ich glaube, diese Sache mit dem Bundestrojaner und Remote Forensik Software, das ist doch mal ein anderer Schnacke, wie man dann an manchen auch noch sagt. Wir haben jetzt erst mal festgestellt, also wenn ich an die Inhalte eines Mobiltelefons ran will, kann ich es auf drei verschiedenen Wegen machen. Welche davon der einfachste ist und welchen wir vielleicht mal selber ausprobieren werden könnten, zum selber basteln. Kleiner Vergleich. Vorher gibt es das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Genau genommen Chaosradio mit Markus Richter und natürlich den Leuten aus dem Chaos Computer Club, Andy Müller-Maguhn und Harald Welte, die euch heute darüber aufklären, wie man so ein Mobiltelefon mal ganz aufwendig und auch unaufwendig überwachen und orten kann. Wir haben schon geklärt im Verlaufe dieser Sendung, was eine funkzellen-Auswertung ist, was Verkehrsdaten sind, was die Vorratsdatenspeicherung bringt, wie man sich selber einen IMSI-Catcher baut. Und jetzt sind wir quasi gerade bei der Creme, nämlich der inhaltlichen Überwachen, also jemanden tatsächlich und wirklich abhören. Wir haben vor der Nachricht schon kurz geklärt, man kann das machen, indem man auch das Telefon selber eine Software spielt, die das vielleicht schon zerledigt. Direkt beim Anbieter und indem man einfach den GSM-Funk abhört. Ich fasse das nochmal zusammen, Harald, was du gerade erzählt hast. Die Software dafür kann man sich aus dem Netz laden und dann selber irgendwie an den Start bringen. Die Hardware dazu kostet 1000 Dollar ungefähr.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also das ist die reine Empfänger-Hardware. Wenn ich noch entschlüsseln will, also die Schlüssel brechen will und die Verschlüsselung, die da eingesetzt wird, dann muss ich noch ein bisschen mehr Geld ausgeben, aber das ist auch nur so ein PC mit zweitigen Grafikkarten.
Okay, da hab ich ja sowieso zu Hause stehen, weil ich gerade Bitcoins generiere. Okay, ich hab jetzt also dieses Ding, also dieses Empfangsgerät, das dropt mir quasi den gesamten GSM-Funk einfach auf meine Platte. Was mach ich dann damit?
Ja, das ist die gute Frage. Was möchtest du tun?
Im Prinzip möchtest du sagen, keine Ahnung, der Fall ist natürlich, dass ich total eifersüchtig bin und die Telefonate meiner Freundin abhören möchte, ohne dass sie es merkt.
Ja, naja gut, vielleicht nochmal aber auch im Allgemeinen, was es da für Herangehensweisen gibt. Ich denke, da gibt es zwei grundsätzlich unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen. Das eine ist eher so die geheimdienstliche Methode. Da will man halt mal alles erfassen, was geht. Und so ein bisschen durch Rasterfahndung, also das Analysieren von Unmengen von Daten, irgendwelche Verhaltensauffälligkeiten herausfinden, soziale Netzwerke von Dissidenten in irgendwelchen Staaten, die halt nicht so freundlich gegenüber irgendwelchen Bürgeraktivitäten gesinnt sind. Solche Dinge, die geheimdienstliche Herangehensweise und dann gibt es eher so die klassisch polizeiliche Herangehensweise. Bei der polizeilichen Herangehensweise, da hat man eben, sei mal im Idealfall eine Ermittlung gegen eine Person oder gegen einen kleinen Personenkreis, und dann will man gezielt diese Personen abhören. Da ist also nicht die Vollerfassung in der Breite, sondern eben wirklich in die Tiefe auf bestimmte Personen. Dazwischen gibt es natürlich alle möglichen Stufen. Und je nachdem, was ich jetzt erfassen will, eignen sich bestimmte Methoden besser oder weniger gut. Also wenn man jetzt sagt, die Polizei in Deutschland möchte, was weiß ich, dies oder jenes ermitteln, dann ist für die Polizei in der Regel das Leichteste, zum Netzpilseiber zu gehen und das irgendwo auf Netzseite zu tun. Da muss man nicht mit Fahrzeugen rumfahren und muss kein spezielles Equipment irgendwo hinstellen und so weiter. Das ist alles teuer, es kostet Geld. Und ja, es ist viel billiger, das auf der Netzseite zu machen. Wenn ich jetzt natürlich als ausländischer Geheimdienst in Deutschland unterwegs bin und irgendwelche deutschen Politiker oder Wirtschaftsgrößen überwachen will, oder die Polizei, oder die deutsche Polizei, oder den deutschen Geheimdienst überwachen will, dann kann ich natürlich nicht zu dem deutschen Netzbetreiber gehen, sagen, hallo, ich hätte hier gerne mal irgendwie überwacht.
Deswegen gründen ja ausländische Geheimdienste Telekommunikationsbetreiber, die dann in Deutschland Netzbetreiber sind, aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Oh, wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Das ist nochmal ein richtig anderes Thema. Oder bin ich jetzt ein organisierter Krimineller?
Also worauf ich eigentlich hinaus soll, ist der technische Ansatz. Weil wir haben ja vorhin schon mal, habt ihr kurz erzählt, irgendwie GSM hat verschiedene Verschlüsselungsstufen. Da gibt es eine, die ist sozusagen eigentlich egal, weil es da quasi Klartext ist. Ihr habt auch gesagt, es gibt verschiedene Sachen, die übertragen werden. Die sind gar nicht verschlüsselt, sondern die kann man einfach so mithören. Ich wollte eigentlich nochmal darauf hinaus sagen, was man da machen muss und wie schwierig das ist.
Wenn man jetzt ganz kurz mal den behördlichen Bereich gesiebt, also die Module, die angeboten werden für Behörden, die Telekommunikationen mit passiven oder semi-passiven Geräten abhören wollen, da zahlt man für so eine Kiste, die A52 macht, zahlt man irgendwas so 100.000.
Aber wir sprechen immer noch von viel Geld für uns.
Ja, gut, das ist ja alles... Also wir reden hier ja von Investition zum Ende. Das ist jetzt aus Sicht einer kriminellen Organisation betrachtet und es geht darum, dass du aus den Erkenntnissen jemanden erpressen willst oder so weiter und so fort, dann redest du okay. Hunderttausend ist ja viel Geld, aber wenn du damit Millionen verdienen kannst, dann ist das ganz wenig Geld. Also man muss das ja mal in Relation sehen mit dem Nutzen, den man damit erzielen kann, auch ökonomisch. Und die teuersten Geschichten oder die aufwendigsten, also A51 kann man sagen zunächst einmal, ist noch im Bereich von, also zumindest den Katalog, den ich in der Hand hatte, da kostete das noch eine Viertel Million. Und A53, das ist also der Angebot, der jetzt auch beim GSM, beim UMTS, also beim 3G eingesetzt wird. Da kenne ich kein Gerät, was man direkt mobil unterwegs betreiben kann. Ich weiß nicht, ob du da schon was gesehen hast, aber...
Nicht direkt, was man da halt macht, also...
Ist da das Dropping auf 2G runter, das man durch gezielte Störungen des Kanals so tut, als gibt es im 3G-Gard irgendein Problem und das Gerät dazu bringt, doch wieder 2G zu machen. Aber das lassen nicht alle Telefone mit sich machen. Ich weiß, dass es im Behördenbereich die Anordnung gibt, bestimmte Geräte nur einzusetzen, die eben genau dieses Feature haben, nämlich sich nicht aus dem 3G rauswerfen zu lassen. Das ist schon ein Sicherheitsfeature.
Ja gut, mal dahingestellt, ja. Aber es gibt diese unterschiedlichen Verschlüsselungsverfahren, die zu knacken. Das gängigste, was man eben heute noch bei den Mobilfunkanbietern findet, also 99% aller Mobiltelefonate in Deutschland zumindest werden über A51 verschlüsselt. Das Verfahren ist seit vielen Jahren in der, sag ich mal, Kryptographenszene gebrochen. Seit, ich weiß nicht mehr, war 1997 die erste Veröffentlichung oder so dazu auf einer kryptographischen Konferenz. Man muss sich auch immer vor Augen halten, das System, über das wir hier reden, GSM, ist eine Entwicklung Mitte der 80er Jahre. Wurde zum ersten Mal eingesetzt 1990, waren die ersten Netze da. Und wir sind jetzt im Jahr 2011. Das heißt, wir sprechen über was, was vor 20, 25 Jahren entwickelt wurde. Da ist natürlich dann auch so ein bisschen klar, dass es einfach heute nicht mehr so den Anforderungen gewachsen ist. Und dass die Computer alle schneller wurden und man Fortschritte gemacht hat im Bereich der Mathematik und so weiter.
Okay, das heißt, was mich hier langsam fragt, wir haben heute schon viel gelernt, weil die meisten Leute benutzen ein Handy quasi als dieses Gerät. Das ist das magische Anmachtding, und dann telefoniere ich damit und das ist schon alles super. Und was man heute auf jeden Fall in den zwei Stunden lernt, ist, das ist also auf relativ vielen Wegen angreifbar. Also viel mehr als ich viele Leute wahrscheinlich vorgestellt habe. Was mich gerade frage ist, wie benutzt ihr denn selber Handys? Also benutzt ihr die überhaupt noch? Oder ist das dann eher so, dass ihr so sagt, ha ha, ne lieber nicht? Oder ist das dann wie bei E-Mail? Da sagen ja die meisten sozusagen datenschutzbewussten Menschen, okay E-Mail muss man wie Postkarte betrachten, da schreibt man eigentlich nichts rein, was man nicht öffentlich sagen würde.
Ich habe vor Jahren mal etwas gelesen, über wie bei der Staatssicherheit Datenverarbeitung funktioniert hat. Und da hat, ich glaube der Büroleiter von Mielke oder sowas, hatte in seinen Memoaren so einen lustigen Abparagrafen, wo er eben gesagt hat, naja, es gab dann bei uns die Aktenvernichter, wenn wir also Akten vernichten wollen, dann gab es die Mülleimer. Und die Mülleimer, da haben wir die Dokumente reingelegt, das war quasi unser Übermittlungsweg an die ausländischen Nachrichtendienste, wenn wir denen etwas mitteilen oder wenn wir denen Desinformationen beimitteln wollten. Und so kann ich persönlich sagen, benutze ich Telekommunikationsfragen zwangsläufig. Natürlich gibt es immer noch Leute, mit denen ich unverschlüsselt telefonieren muss, aber es gibt eben auch Verschlüsselungstelefone, wo ich zufällig was mit zu tun habe. Aber davon unabhängig, also natürlich kommt man nicht drumrum, unverschlüsselt, wir sagen auf dem normalen Telefonnetz zu telefonieren, aber trotzdem will man da eben nicht alle Gespräche führen, ganz sicher nicht. Und das ist das Problem an der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das Ganze führt zwangsläufig zu einer Verhaltensänderung.
Ja, und da muss man auch wieder unterscheiden, die Verschlüsselung selber bringt dir bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ja auch nichts. Die Inhalte kann ich noch so sehr schützen, diese Verkehrsdaten, die fallen trotzdem an.
Na ja, es kommt drauf an.
Na ja, man kann da schon auch noch Dinge verschleiern und so weiter.
Das ist ja durchaus eine spannende Frage, weil nach dem, was wir heute hier gehört haben, ist es so, sobald mein Handy an ist, bin ich ja sozusagen da drin.
Das ist richtig. Wenn du auf die Art und Weise deine Gespräche aufbaust, dass du einen Datenkanal zwischen dir und deinem Kommunikationspartner aufbaust und darüber direkt verschlüsselst, das von deinem Mobiltelefon machst, dann sieht man das unter Umständen im Netz. Aber wenn man erst noch über ein Servernetzwerk geht, wo eben das Ganze eher aussieht wie eine VPN-Verbindung, dann kann man da schon was machen. Und zumindest für Messaging gibt es schon funktionierende Sachen, wo das eben über Tor geht, also über so ein Anonymisierungsnetzwerk. Und ich würde mal kognostizieren, so in ein paar Jahren wird es das auch für Sprache geben. Das hängt im Moment noch an der Latenz, also an der Verzögerung, die da entsteht, wenn man eine Anonymisierung der Datenverbindung quasi betreibt. Das ist im Moment funktioniert, das für Sprache einfach gar nicht.
Ja, also das ist sicherlich möglich. Man kann da Dinge tun, aber es sind immer sowas wie, wo ist dieses Telefon gerade, das ist einfach eine Information, die zwangsweise dem Mobiltelefonnetz bekannt sein muss. Die müssen ja wissen, über welchen Sende-Masten können sie gerade mit deinem Telefon reden. Also wissen sie, wo dein Telefon ist.
Klar, wenn du in ein Mobilnetz eingebucht bist.
Also das gibt eben bestimmte Grenzen, da kommt man nicht drum rum.
Du kannst ja über IP telefonieren, da benutzt du einfach das nächste WLAN. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass es keine Alternativen gibt, um mobile Telekommunikation zu machen.
Naja, also eine wirkliche Alternative würde ich es nicht ansehen. Also du kannst das Telefon ausschalten, du kannst irgendwie einen öffentlichen Münz Fernsprecher benutzen.
Ich kann hier verschlüsselt über WLAN telefonieren, brauche ich kein GSM, brauche ich nicht im GSM-Netz.
Ja, dann bist du nicht im GSM-Netz, aber du bist irgendwie hier im IP-Netz, was genauso Vorratsdaten irgendwie anlegt. Fast.
Wieso? Wo liegt das Vorratsdaten dann?
Naja, weil es einen Internetprovider gibt, der hier dem Rundfunk Berlin Brandenburg irgendwie einen Internetanschluss legt und der ist auch wieder unterliegt der Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung.
Aber nicht im selben Umfang wie ein Telekommunikationsanbieter. Also, okay, da gibt es schon Unterschiede in Bezug auf wer Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen in welcher Form anbringt. Ich sehe da schon auch eine Chance drin, dass das IP sozusagen andere Möglichkeiten bietet, weil wir sind ja auch gerade jetzt mal unabhängig von dem Überwachungsthema. Das gesamte Telefonnetz wird ja gerade quasi umgestellt und die zu Grunde liegen über Traumstechnik, die bislang esoterische Angelegenheiten wie ATM waren und irgendwelche X-Protokolle. Das wird ja alles auf IP gerade geschmissen. Und auf der einen Seite ist das ein riesen Problem, weil die Verfügbarkeit, also unter dem Aspekt der Betriebssicherheit, ist das eigentlich ein riesen Problem, weil die ganzen Internetprobleme jetzt auch ins Telefonnetz reinkommen. Aber auf der anderen Seite kommen auch die ganzen Chancen, die Daten ganz anders zu handhaben und ganz anders zu verteilen und auch zwischendurch zu verschlüsseln. Solche Sachen, die bislang sehr mühselig waren mit anderen Protokollen, die geraten jetzt auch im Bereich der Möglichkeiten für die Telekommunikation. Das ist auch eine Chance.
Ist der Ausblick zu sagen eher optimistisch, weil Harald, du meinst jetzt die ganze Zeit, wir telefonieren mit einer Technik aus den 80er Jahren. Würdest du sagen, in der nächsten Zeit was tun, wo man sagen kann, mobile Datenübertragung, das müsste man wahrscheinlich dann schon sagen, wird zeitgemäß?
Ich habe eine beschränkte Hoffnung. Spätestens bei LTE. Wenn man das GSM hat, danach kommt 3G, dann kann man noch sagen 35G, also HSPA-beschleunigte Verfahren. Dann kommt 4G, also das LTE-System, wo jetzt die ersten Basis-Stationen irgendwo in Brandenburg und irgendwie in was weiß ich wo stehen. Da gibt es keine klassische leitungsgebundene Telefonie mehr in diesem System. Das ist alles nur noch Internet, das ist alles nur noch IP. Telefonie gibt es an sich nicht mehr, da macht man halt dann Voice-over-IP. Ab dem Zeitpunkt, das ist was Andy eben angesprochen hat, da ist es natürlich spätestens da ist es dann so, Voice-over-IP-Telefonie und da gibt es durchaus mehr Möglichkeiten, dass man mit anderer Software einfach zusätzliche Verschlüsselung nachrüstet und derartige Dinge tut.
Aber man sollte jetzt das nicht missverstehen, dass das auch der Fall ist. Also wenn wir sagen, das kann man, dann ist das halt, das erschließt Möglichkeiten. Aber im Moment laufen wir eigentlich in einem Szenario rum, wo die behördlichen, nachrichtendienstlichen und sonstigen Interessierten, die ein Budget dafür haben, sehr weitflächig, einen sehr großen Umfang Telekommunikationsdaten nicht nur abhören, im Sinne von mitlesen, ihnen Erfahrungen bringen, sondern vor allem speichern können. Weil man muss sehen, dass es wirklich dramatisch günstig ist, Telekommunikationsdaten auch in großem Umfang einfach wegzuspeichern. Eine 2 TB Festplatte kostet jetzt gerade noch 80 Euro netto. Und da kriegt man schon eine Menge drunter.
Es gibt ja, wenn wir auf dem Rechner kommunizieren, gibt es klare Ansagen von Leuten, die Plan haben, verschlüsselt euer Zeug, guckt zu, dass ihr anonym im Netz unterwegs seid. Gibt es eine einfache Anweisung für uns Handybenutzer, gerade bevor wir in der schönen neuen LTE Welt ankommen? Gibt es Hinweise zur Handynutzung, die ihr gibt?
Da kann man nicht viel hinweisen.
Man kann schon darauf hinweisen. Ich habe mich mal damit beschäftigt, wie in Botschaften, Telekommunikationssicherheit und so etwas realisiert wird. In bestimmten Besprechungsräumen werden Mobiltelefone vorher an der Garderobe abgegeben. Da gibt es da eigene Fächer für. Es gibt auch einen Service, der wenn ein Telefon klingelt, dass derjenige den Raum verlässt und in Ruhe draußen telefonieren kann. Aber wenn man Vertraulichkeit des Wortes will, dann sitzt man nicht in einem Raum, in dem Mobiltelefone sich befinden. Weil man muss ja auch mal sehen, diese Remotrojaner, die können unter Umständen nicht nur die Gespräche des Telefons bei einem Telefongespräch abhören, sondern auch einfach das Gerät in ein mikrofonsendendes Wanzenteil sozusagen verwandeln. Und das kann man schon als Hinweis verstehen. Es gibt auch im professionellen Bereich dann Jammer, mit dem man die Frequenzen plattlegt. Das ist allerdings unter Umständen nicht erlaubt, wie auch der Einsatz von aktiven Geräten, weil man die Frequenzen des Netzbetreiber stört. Und es gibt auch Verschlüsselungstelefonie und Methoden, um SMSen zu verschlüsseln und ähnliches.
Das ist ja noch relativ teuer, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Wir reden hier über Equipment, was man sich in der großen Industrie leistet, was man sich im wirklich staatlichen Bereich leistet, wo es um hohe Würdenträger und Geheimnisträger geht. Ich habe mal eine Zahl gehört, dass es in Deutschland insgesamt für sämtliche öffentliche Beschäftigte, also von Behörden egal welcher Art, nur 2000 Telefone gibt, die verschlüsseln. Also die, die diese End-zu-End-Verschlüsselung haben.
Woran liegt das eigentlich? Warum sind Telefone noch so rumgefragt? Warum sind Telefone, die verschlüsseln können, noch so teuer? Es gibt ja auf dem Rechner, man kann jetzt irgendwie einen PGP halten. Sonst lad ich mir runter, installiere ich fertig.
Ja, aber dann hast du noch das Problem, dass du nicht die Betriebssystemsicherheit im Griff hast. Das heißt, wenn du deine Nachricht verschlüsselst, dann hast du damit sichergestellt, dass auf dem Transportweg die Nachricht, die abgehört wird, dem Angreifer nichts nützt. Aber du hast damit nicht verhindert, dass ein Trojaner auf deinem Rechner die Nachrichten bevor sie verschlüsselt werden, während sie verschlüsselt werden. Und beim Mobilfunk ist genau das der kritische Punkt. Es gibt Software, die kannst du dir für die Smartphones teilweise sehr günstig im Netz herunterladen. Die machen aber nur Sparverschlüsse. Die sichern nicht dein Gerät gegen Angriffe ab. Und der künstliche Ansatz beides zu machen ist halt relativ viel Aufwand.
Okay, das ist klar. Das ist mir auch klar, sozusagen. Und das ist ja auch genau so, dass du sagen, auf deinem eigenen Rechner hast du genau immer das Problem. Aber was ich halt die Frage war, tatsächlich die eher, wenn ich wenigstens diesen einen Schritt gehen will.
Das ist eine Frage der Kontrolle und wie die Technik angelegt ist. Also wenn ich jetzt den PC anschaue, da ist die Hardware relativ offen spezifiziert. Man kann da beliebige Betriebssysteme drauf installieren. Ich kann da Linux, FreeBSD, Windows, Schlag mich tot, was auch immer darauf installieren. Und dann kann ich auf dem Betriebssystem beliebige Anwendungen installieren. Und die tun mit der Hardware in der Regel das, was ich halt irgendwie von ihr will oder was ich für Dinge drauf... Also zumindest sag ich mal, als Entwickler sollte ich da irgendwie oder als IT-Mensch sollte ich da in der Lage sein zu kontrollieren, was da passiert oder auch nicht. Auf den Mobiltelefonen ist es eben so, dass man in der Regel, zumindest bei Smartphones, hat man im Prinzip zwei kleine Computer in so einem Telefon drin. Das ist wie so ein Zweigehörn. Und der eine Teil... Es gibt da auch so Split-Brain-Syndrom. Also manchmal behauptet der eine Teil, das wäre so, und der andere denkt was anderes. Also der eine Teil dieses Telefons ist sozusagen das echte Telefon, das was mit dem Mobilfunknetz interagiert. Das ist der sogenannte Baseband-Prozessor. Und da drauf läuft halt Software, die entweder vom Telefonentwickler, aber meistens eigentlich von dem Chipsats-Entwickler kommt. Und dies extrem zugenagelt, da kann niemand irgendwas... Zumindest ist nicht vorgesehen, dass irgendjemand was zusätzlich installiert. Das heißt selbst auf einem Android oder was auch immer Telefon, wo ich tausend Dinge auf diesem Prozessor, wo eben das Android-System drauf läuft, nachinstallieren kann und verändern kann. Das betrifft überhaupt nicht diesen Baseband-Prozessor. Und da läuft diese ganze klassische Telefonie drauf. Und demnach sind sehr wenige Firmen, ich würde mal sagen ungefähr fünf auf der Welt, überhaupt in der Lage dort, diese Software zu verändern oder neue Funktionen dort einzubauen.
Also es ist quasi von mir ein Missverständnis gewesen, dass ich sage, wir haben noch diese krassen Smartphones, die alle tausend Sachen können, weil die gibt es zwar, aber der große Smartphone-Rechner, der drin ist, der hat mit diesem kleinen Telefonrechner, der völlig abgekapstelt ist, gar nichts mehr zu tun.
Nur eingeschränkt, da gibt es natürlich Interfaces dazwischen, aber es gibt noch eine weitere Dimension, die man erwähnen kann, nämlich, dass wenn man so ein Gerät absichern will, dann hast du A diesen Computerteil und dann hast du B diesen Baseband-Teil und es gibt halt auch Angriffe auf den Baseband. Das heißt, dass du ein Mobiltelefon, der zwar unabhängig von dem Betriebssystem, was da installiert ist, über die GSM-Schnittstelle, die es natürlich haben muss, weil sonst kannst du damit nicht telefonieren, angegriffen werden können, weil das ist wie gesagt auch nur ein Computer. Von Menschen programmiertes Software. Und auch da gibt es natürlich Exploits, also Programmierfehler, die sich ausnutzen lassen, um wiederum da weiter im Gerät irgendwas zu tun.
Nur um mal eine Größenordnung vielleicht zu bekommen, was da an Software läuft, das ist ein kleiner Telefon-Teil. Wir reden da inzwischen auch leicht über eine Komplexität von 3 bis 8 Millionen Zeilen Code, die da laufen, nur auf diesem Telefon-Teil.
Okay, ich möchte mir das nicht durchlesen. Hat sich schon mal jemand die Bühr gemacht, das zu Reverse-Engineeren, also rauszufinden, was da für Code läuft? Oder ist das sowieso öffentlich verfügbar?
Öffentlich verfügbar ist es nicht. Es gibt Leute, die da dran arbeiten. Und jetzt gerade im Hinblick auf diese Exploitbarkeit, also da Schadsoftware drauf zu installieren und eben Sicherheitslücken auszunutzen, da gab es auf mehreren Veranstaltungen letztes Jahr Vorträge von Ralf-Philipp Weinmann dazu. Der hat also sowohl bei aktuellen iPhones als auch bei Android-Telefonen jeweils Lücken gefunden, mit denen er in der Lage war, diese Telefone automatisch antworten zu lassen. Das heißt also, er schickt eine spezielle Nachricht über das GSM-Netz an das Telefon und danach der nächste eingehende Anruf, dann nimmt das Telefon sofort ab, ohne dass der Anwender irgendwie den Ich nehme mal den Anruf an-Knopf drücken muss.
Sehr schön, da haben wir heute wieder viel gelernt über Mobiltelefone. Ich breche es an dieser Stelle einfach mal ab, weil alles noch mal zusammenzufassen würde wahrscheinlich jetzt noch mal zwei Stunden dauern. Ich sage auf jeden Fall schon mal vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart. Ich würde auf jeden Fall noch fragen wollen, wenn man sich für das Thema jetzt weitergehen interessiert, was sind gute Ansatzpunkte im Netz, wo klicke ich, um mal sagen genauer dazu zu lesen?
Tja, wir könnten natürlich versuchen, noch mal eine kleine Linksammlung zur Sendung zusammenzustellen. Früher haben wir das auch mal geschafft bei Chaosradio Sendung. Was wir vielleicht jetzt noch tun könnten, wären die Stichworte für die Suchmaschine eurer Wahl zu geben.
Es gibt einfach mal Chaos Communication Congress Präsentationen nach GSM-Suchen oder derartigen Dingen. Es gab Vorträge zu Airprobe, zu Kraken. Das sind diese Abhörangriffe. Also rein passiv die Luftschnittstelle mit Lauschen von Carsten Nohl beispielsweise. Es gibt von Ralf-Philipp Weinmann eben diese Vorträge zu den Baseband-Exploits. Es gibt Vorträge zu OpenBTS und OpenBSC. Also wenn man einfach mal die IT-Security-Konferenz in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren abklappert, zu allem was mit GSM zu tun hat, da denke ich, ist man dann ganz gut informiert.
Okay, die Schlagworte habt ihr jetzt. Also könnt ihr noch mal googeln. Wer weiß, vielleicht schaffen ist ja sozusagen Seltsamer Heintel, wenn die noch mal so eine Linkliste zu bauen. Die würde dann ins Blog geworfen werden wahrscheinlich. Vicky, stimmt. Es gibt ja einen Vicky. Ihr könnt selber, wenn ihr jetzt und so weiter und so fort, ihr wisst, wie das funktioniert.
Haben wir nicht den Ausstieg aus der Vicky-Technologie beschlossen?
Also okay, das ist vielleicht eine Diskussion, die wir an eine andere Stelle führen. Das könnte auch länger dauern, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Traditionell macht ihr noch ein bisschen Werbung am Ende der Sendung. Ich habe gerüchteweise gehört, es steht ein runder Geburtstag an.
Ja, nun gut, es gibt ja zwei Ereignisse. Also Baus Todestag ist in vier Minuten, also wir sagen, ist morgen jetzt nicht so ein zehnmal, aber das ist natürlich eigentlich kein freudiges Ereignis. Trotzdem ist es auch anders, darüber nachzudenken, dass der Chaos Computer Club in diesem Jahr 30 Jahre wird. Das ist allerdings erst am 12. September. Gegründet ist er ja in den Räumen der Taz im Rahmen eines sogenannten 2-Watt-Kongresses. Und wir hatten schon mal den Versuch, die 20-jährige Geburtstagsfeier zu machen. Das war am 12. September 2001. Wir hatten eine Pressekonferenz am Vormittag des 11. September 2001, die die Veranstaltung ankündigen wollten. Wir hatten extra den Kongressalarm Alexanderplatz angemietet, die Ausstellungsfläche und so weiter. Aber irgendwie war am Nachmittag des 11. September 2001 ein anderes Thema, was uns völlig aus den Zeitungen verdrängt hat. Deswegen ist unsere 20-jährige Geburtstagsfeier so gut wie ausgefallen. Da ist keiner gekommen zur Ausstellung.
Und jetzt plant ihr keine 30-jährige, weil da möglicherweise wieder sowas passiert?
Ja, also soweit würde ich nicht gehen. Aber wir sind noch in der Konzeptionsphase. Wir haben noch kein echtes Konzept.
Okay, dann legen wir jetzt nicht weit über umgelegt. Also 30 Jahre auf jeden Fall. Und das Datum kommt noch her, war noch nicht. Manche Zeitungen erwecken einen anderen Eindruck. Außerdem gibt es den nächsten Camp, 10. bis 14. August. Im Sendungschat war gerade die Frage, wird es dort auch ein GSM-Netzwerk geben?
Ja, selbstverständlich. Auf den CTC-Veranstaltungen der letzten Jahre hatten wir eigentlich immer ein GSM-Netz zu Testzwecken. Das heißt, wir haben unser eigenes Mobilfunknetz. Da können die Leute sich einbuchen, können damit experimentieren, können damit spielen, können all die Dinge legal tun, die sie im echten Netz nie tun dürfen.
So, könnt ihr also hinfahren? Wo ist das nochmal?
In Finowood bei Eberswalde.
Alles klar. So, dann war's das. Diese Sendung wird es euch demnächst auch als Podcast geben. Sehr bald auf fritz.de und dann ein bisschen später auf chaosradio.ccc.de. So rum. Vielen Dank euch beiden nochmal für's Hiersein und Mitmachen. Gerne. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Und ich sag noch das, was ich immer an meiner Sendung sage, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.